TO THE SENATE BUDGET-
SUBCOMMITTEE TO MY NAME'S BOB I
CAST HIM STILL THE CHAIR OF
THIS UBCOMMITTEE BUT I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR NEW COLLEAGUE
CENTER DOLLY WHO IS REPLACING
SEC OWNS IS OUR RANKING
MINORITY MEMBER CENTER ALI GOOD
MORNING. I'M REFER. ROLE IS IT
I'M SUBCOMMITTEE IS TO ASK THE
TOUGH QUESTIONS WERE. WE
SCRUTINIZE THE BY CHANGE ORDER.
WE MAKE SURE THAT THIS
EXPENDITURE AND JUSTIFY. IN
CONSTANT USE OF THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL RESOURCES WE TAKE
VERY EVERY MEMBER OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TAKES A SERIOUS
THEIR CHARGES THESE ARE PUBLIC
RESOURCES THAT WERE SPENDING.
AND IT'S OUR ROLE TO BE. IT
TAKES THINGS. HERE IS AND NOT
LIKE. I'M WERE RESPONSE TO
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS IT SHOULD BE
UTILIZED. IN WISELY. AND MAY
SURE THAT THEY ARE GETTING THE
MOSTOUT OF THEIR DOLLARS AND
THEIR AGENCIES TO RUN.
EFFECTIVELY WEATHER'S THE FIELD
OF ENERGY. TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENT AND PROTECTING OF
OUR RESOURCES. I AM TODAY WE'LL
START OFF WITH AN UPDATE FROM
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE
UNDER BASE BUDGET REVIEW WITH
DIRECTOR BOTTOM AND THEN MOVE
ON TO OUR REGULAR GENDER. EVERY
YEAR I DEAL WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
DIFFERENTLY SO I MIGHT AS WELL
GIVE EVERYBODY A- OF- HEADS UP
ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
HIDDEN IN FISCAL- TWENTY TWENTY
WE WILL HAVE OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AFTER EACH ITEM SO
WE'RE NOT WAIT TILL THE END OF
THE DEPARTMENT OR NOT THE WAY
TO THE END OF THE- HEARING
AFTER WE HAVE AFTER WE- HERE
THE MATTER. AND MEMBERS
QUESTION I WILL OPEN IT UP
REPUBLICAN IT WILL TAKE A
LITTLE BIT LONGER BUT- WE MAY
BE MORE FOCUS SO WITH THAT.
DIRECTOR BOTTOM. LET'S LET'S
START OFF THIS IS. LET'S CALL
THE ROLL ESTABLISH KERR. MY
CASKEY HERE ALI REQUIRE MINING
THIRTY. I A QUORUM IS. A RING
MINORITY CENTER DOLLY HIS FOR
THAT ITEM NUMBER ALLOW HE
PULLED FROM THE VA ONLY ONLY
SOLD THAT WHEN WE BRING UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCE I'M WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUES. ONE
TWO THREE FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
NINE. ARE THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR IS A MOTION DOLLY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LIKE HOUSE
HI ALI. WHEN SHE LIKE. ONE TWO
FIVE. OKAY NEXT MCGUIRE. MONEY
DURING. OKAY WILL KEEP THOSE
MATTERS OPEN IS THERE A MOTION
ON ISSUES NUMBER FOUR IN TEN.
SENATOR MCGUIRE MOVES PLEASE
CALL ROLL CASKEY HI ALI.
REQUIRE. MORNING DURING KEEP
THAT MATTER OPEN UP FOR LATER
LET'S MOVE TO OUR INFORMATIONAL.
A HEARING. GOOD MORNING
DIRECTOR HOW WHAT A BETTER WAY
FOR SOME TO THE START OFFICE
IT'S A- HERE WITH AN UPDATE ON
OUR BUDGET BASED. PROGRAM.
THANK HERE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHUCK BONHAM AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THANK YOU FOR CARVING OUT A FEW
MINUTES IN AN OTHERWISE BUSY
DAY. I MENTIONED IT YESTERDAY
AND THE ASSEMBLY I HAVE ONE
GOAL FOR THE NEXT FIVE OR TEN
MINUTES. THAT'S TO MAKE THIS AN
EXCITING. CAPTIVATING TELLING
PRESENTATION EVEN THOUGH IT'S
ENTIRELY ABOUT BUSINESS
ANALYTICS I WANNA PAINTERS
STORY FOR YOU TAKE YOU ON A
JOURNEY. A WALK AROUND OF
THINGS WE'VE BEEN DOING AT THE
DEPARTMENT YOU HAVE A SERIES OF
SLIDES LET'S CALL THE COVER
SLIDE SLIDE ONE AND SLIDE TO IS.
PHOTO OF TWO BIRDS WITH A FISH
STUCK IN THE MIDDLE. FLYING THE
ABSENT GEN AND FOR US LIFE IN
OUR DEPARTMENT OFTEN FEELS LIKE
BEING THAT FISH STUCK BETWEEN
COMPETING INTERESTS. SO FROM
THAT PLATFORM WHAT IS SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING. IT TURNS OUT
IT'S ACTUALLY A BUSINESS
DISCIPLINE PEOPLE STUDIED IN
GRADUATE SCHOOL THERE'S A
MANAGEMENT FIELD ABOUT IT. IT'S
FOCUSED ON TASKS OF AN
ENTERPRISE LABOR OF AN
ENTERPRISE ORGANIZATION OF THAT
ENTERPRISE IT'S ITERATIVE. AND
IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH CERTAIN
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT VALUES.
THOSE ARE EFFICIENCIES
TRANSPARENCY INCLUSIVITY TRUST.
SO WE AT THE DEPARTMENT ARE
ENGAGED IN SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING WE HAVE FOUR GOALS
YOU'LL SEE THEM THERE ON PAGE
TWO. ASIAN BIRD PHOTO WE WANTED
TO FIND OUR SERVICE STANDARDS
WE WANNA GET TO DETAILED COST
ESTIMATES WE WANT TO COMPARE
OUR SERVICE TO OUR MISSION
LEVEL RESPONSIBILITIES. AND WE
ARE ONE ANALYZE OUR REVENUE
FUNDING AND STRUCTURE. BUT HOW
DID WE GET HERE. IT'S ACTUALLY
A SEVENTY YEAR ISSUE. I HAVE IN
MY FILES A REPORT FROM NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY MANAGEMENT FIRM
CALLED BOOZ ALLEN HAMILTON.
THEY DID A REPORT FOR THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT THEY
CONCLUDED OUR DEPARTMENT
SUFFERED FROM LACK OF
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTUALLY AMENDED
THE FISH AND GAME CODE. SECTION
SEVEN TEN POINT FIVE SAYS THAT
A LEGISLATIVE FINDING LEVEL THE
DEPARTMENT SUFFERS FROM LACK OF
STABLE FUNDING NEEDS TO SECURE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING. COME INTO
THE TWO THOUSANDS THE
LEGISLATURE SPOKE AGAIN. IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN ELEVEN IT CREATED
A BLUE RIBBON PANEL TO TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR DEPARTMENT. I HAD
THE ODD EXPERIENCE OF BEING A
BLUE RIBBON PANEL MEMBER. AND
THEN BECOMING DIRECTOR. OF THE
DEPARTMENT DURING THAT PROCESS.
IT ENDED WITH A REPORT OF
TWENTY EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS.
COME INTO THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN. IN THE
LEGISLATURE AGAIN SPOKE. YOU
TOLD US TO RECONVENE THE BLUE
RIBBON PANEL. COALITION YOU
TOLD US TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
THE PROGRESS WE HAD MADE ON
THIS TWENTY EIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND YOU TOLD
US TO ENGAGE IN A MISSION BASED
BUDGET REVIEW PROCESS WE
STARTED THAT. THEN YOU GET TO
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN AND THAT'S THE
MOST RELEVANT INSTRUCTION.
YOU'VE GIVEN US RECENTLY. YOU
ACTUALLY APPROVE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THREE YEARS AND
THIRTY POSITIONS CONTINGENT ON.
COMPLETING SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. YOU LAID OUT A
SERIES OF MILESTONES WE IN MY
JUDGMENT HAVE HIT EVERY
MILESTONE YOU PUT IN STATUTE.
HERE'S WHAT WE'VE DONE. WE
RECONVENE THAT EXTERNAL
COMMUNITY IT'S AN EIGHTY PLUS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I
REDIRECTED ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY OF OUR LEADERSHIP STAFF
THE FOCUS ON THIS ENDEAVOR. OUR
DIALOGUE OVER THE LAST CALENDAR
YEAR HAS INVOLVED YOUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF SUBJECT MATTER
STAFF FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
THAT EIGHTY PLUS EXTERNAL
COMMUNITY. AND NOW SHE COULD
TURN TO SLIDE THREE. THE HIGHER
IS CDF W. SERVICE AREAS. FIRST
THING WE DID WITH THAT MULTI
PARTY GROUP. WE FORCED
OURSELVES TO STOP USING
BUREAUCRATIC LINGO ON HOW WE
DESCRIBE WHAT WE DO. AND WE USE
THAT GROUP TO HELP US FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO DESCRIBE OUR
SERVICE AREASIN PLAINER
LANGUAGE. THAT'S THESE EIGHT
CATEGORIES YOU NOW SEE. SO IT'S
NOT LIKE WE BLEW UP
ORGANIZATIONAL HIERARCHY BOXES
AS MUCH AS WE THOUGHT ABOUT HOW
TO GROUP SERVICE. INTO
COMPONENTS THE PUBLIC CAN
UNDERSTAND. AND IF YOU ROLL
OVER TO THE NEXT SLIDE. WHICH
HAS A PICTURE OF ONE OF OUR
OFFICERS WITH BINOCULARS. WE
TOOK THOSE EIGHT SERVICE AREAS
IN OVER THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
DONE THESE THINGS. HERE'S THE
CORE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
YOU LIST OUT EVERY TASK THE
BUSINESS DOES. WE CAME UP WITH
THE TASK REGISTRY OF ALMOST
THREE THOUSAND TASKS. THEN YOU
FIGURE OUT WHAT LABOR HOURS ARE
BEING SPENT ON EACH TASK. AND
THEN YOU COMPARE THE SERVICE
CURRENTLY AGAINST AN ESTIMATE
OF WHAT YOUR SERVICE WOULD BE
IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY HITTING YOUR
MISSION. ALL YOUR MANDATES.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ENGAGED IN
AND HAVE COMPLETED AS OF LAST
YEAR. THAT TAKES YOU TO THE
NEXT SLIDE SLIDE FIVE WHICH IS
KIND OF THE BEGINNING OF THE
MONEY SLIDE IF YOU WILL IN THE
SENSE THAT WHAT YOU GET AFTER
DOING THAT EXERCISE. IS AN
ABILITY TO FIGURE OUT THE GAS.
BETWEEN WHERE YOU ARE AND WHERE
YOU'RE COMMUNITY EUREX COLONEL
FOLKS AND YOUR BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE THINK YOU NEED TO BE.
BUT IMPORTANTLY YOU DON'T HAVE
TO FILL A GAP JUST ADDING LABOR
HOURS. THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
DEAL WITH YOUR GAP PROBLEMS YOU
CAN. GET RID OF OLD ARCHAIC
MANDATES. YOU CAN ACHIEVE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS YOU CAN
INCREASE YOUR PARTNERSHIPS
WHICH CAN BRING DOWN YOUR GAP.
YOU CAN INVEST IN TECHNOLOGY
AND EQUIPMENT OF COURSE YOU
COULD DO LABOR AS WELL. SO WHAT
YOU'LL SEE IN THE NEXT SLIDE
WHICH IS TOTAL PRELIMINARY DATA%
ANALYSIS. TOOK A LONG TIME TO
VAT WITH SOME OF YOUR STAFF IN
THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS ENGAGED. THIS IS A-
GRAPHIC REPRESENTATION OF WHAT
YOU SEE. AFTER YEARS WORTH THE
WORK WITH ALL THE PARTIES AND
DELOITTE ILLUSTRATING THE GAP.
THE GAP IS BIGGEST IN SPECIES
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION AND
PERMITTING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. THIS IS A METRIC
BASED ON LABOR HOURS THAT'S THE
WAY THE TEMPLATE AND- THE
ARITHMETIC WORKS. SO WHAT'S
LEFT TO HAD TO DO. WELL WE
WE'VE GOT TO DO A COUPLE THINGS.
WE GOTTA CREATE THE DIGITAL AND
ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE THAT THIS
BECOMES THE INTEREST TOOL WE'RE
USING EVERY YEAR GOING FORWARD.
WE'RE DOING WELL I'M CREATING
THAT WE'VE GOT A TRAIN ALMOST
THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT THIS
IS OUR NEW BUSINESS AS USUAL
WAY TO THINK ABOUT BUDGETING.
WE WANTED TO BE AN ITERATIVE
TOOL YOU CAN ASK US QUESTIONS
WE CAN RESPOND PRETTY QUICKLY
AND THIS KIND OF. LAY OUT IN
FORMAT. EVERY YEAR WE WILL
UPDATE THE SERVICE LEVEL DATA.
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE WILL UPDATE
THE MISSION LEVEL ESTIMATES.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO GOT TO GET
INTO OUR REVENUE SIDE OF THE
HOUSE WE HAVE ONE OF THE MORE
COMPLICATED ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS
BECAUSE OF A WHOLE VAST ARRAY
OF DEDICATED ACCOUNTS. AND
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THE NEXT
PHASE KIND OF ON PACKING THAT
WITH THIS EXTERNAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IN WITH YOU. BUT I
WANT TO END BY SAYING REALLY I
THINK SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
IS JUST. TOOL ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT'S ENTIRELY DIFFERENT. I
THINK WE HAVE A CHOICE. AND THE
CHOICE IS ONE WE COLLECTIVELY
SHARES CALIFORNIANS. WHAT DO WE
WANT OUR FUTURE TO BE WE HAVE A
MOMENT IN TIME. I'M MOTIVATED
BY A HIGH SENSE OF URGENCY. OUR
DEPARTMENT THINKS ABOUT OUR
MISSION IN TWENTY TWENTY AS
SAVING NATURE. THAT'S IT. IT'S
A NATURE THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM
BEES THE BUTTERFLIES TO THE
KELP FOREST TO WHALES IN THE
OCEAN TO MOUNTAIN LIONS. WE DO
THINGS WE'RE CELEBRATING OUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY. THE VERY FIRST
WILDLIFE AGENCY IN THE WAR IN
THE NATION WAS THE BOARD OF
FISH COMMISSIONERS A HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AGO. WHAT WE DO SO
MUCH MORE TODAY. THAT THOSE
FOLKS COULDN'T IMAGINE BACK
THEN. IT'S ABOUT PRESERVING
LAND WATER AND WILDLIFE AS PART
OF A STRONG AND THRIVING
ECONOMY SO THIS INFORMATION
IT'S ABOUT SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BIRD SPECIES THAT ARE
NATIVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
MAMMALS SEVENTY FIVE AND VIVIAN
SPECIES ALL HUNDRED MARINE FISH
AND MARINE MAMMAL SPECIES IN
OUR GREAT OCEAN OFF SHORE. YES
SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PLANT
TAX ON THIS STATE TWO THOUSAND
OF THEM ARE RARE AND FOUND NO
WHERE ELSE WE HAVE MORE. RARE
PLANTS IN THIS STATE THAN ALL
THE OTHER FORTY. A LOWER
CONNELL STATE'S COMBINED. IT'S
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES IT'S
ALMOST FIVE THOUSAND LAKES AND
RESERVOIRS ELEVEN HUNDRED MILE
COASTLINE CALIFORNIA CURRENT
OFF SHORE. IS THE DESERT'S A
FARCE THE MEADOWS THE ESTUARIES
THE RANGE LAND THE ACLAND ITS
PEOPLE. IT'S ABOUT CREATING A
FUTURE THAT'S ALL INCLUSIVE
AROUND THAT EXPERIENCE OF
NATURE AS PART OF IT INTER
CONNECTED WITH THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
THAT'S TWO WE THINK WE ARE THE
DEPARTMENT RELATIVE TO OUR
MISSION. SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING IS LETTING US. USE
DATA TO IDENTIFY HOW TO DO
GOVERNMENT BETTER. HOW TO BUILD
OUR BUDGET MORE SMARTLY AND HOW
TO CREATE THAT KIND OF FUTURE.
THAT'S MY UPDATE ON THIS
INFORMATION A LOT OF. WILL
PROBABLY JUMP INTO IT WHEN WE
GET TO OUR ITEMS LET'S. SEE TO
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN THIS IS
OUR- THE NON CONTROVERSIAL
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
TRANSFER. WE ARE HERE WE GO
AGAIN. IT'S JUST THAT WAS JUST.
YEAH RIGHT. SO CHAIR MEMBERS WE
TRY SOMETHING UNUSUAL. AND JUST
START WITH AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT.
I KNOW. THAT YOU'RE LIKELY TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN THAT'S THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE ASSEMBLY
YESTERDAY. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I TOOK SOME VERY
DIRECT AND SHARP QUESTIONS
APPROPRIATELY. SELECT COMMITTEE.
I UNDERSTAND I ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REACTION THAT THE FUNDS WHAT
HAS TRIGGERED GET THAT. BUT I'D
LIKE TO DO FIRST THOUGH KNOWING
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUES JUST
KIND OF LAY OUT THE SUBSTANCE
OF THE PROPOSAL IF THAT'S OKAY.
YEAH THAT'S ALL RIGHT WE SORT
OF WENT THROUGH THIS THREE
YEARS AGO YES HIGHER FUN BUT IT
IS A DIFFERENT. THAT THAT IS
VERY MUCH FOR ME I MEAN I'VE
BEEN THROUGH THIS WITH TIRE
FUND WITH MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT
I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN TO IT WAS
CENTER MCGUIRE AND YOU ONE
RAISING COME FISHING FEES I MAY
HAVE A. FEEL FOR. THIS IS LIVE.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO DETRACT.
THIS THAT'S- WITHIN THE- I
THINK VERY REMARKABLE PROPOSAL.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET IT'S
ABOUT. DATE IT'S ABOUT TRYING
TO CREATE THAT VISION IT'S
ABOUT TRYING TO CREATE THAT
CALIFORNIA THAT'S NATURE FOR
ALL IN HERE'S HOW IT'S ABOUT
THOSE THINGS I'M DIRECTOR BONTA
MIKE I SUSPECTED SOME OF MY
MEMBERS HERE WILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS OF FINANCE BECAUSE
WELL WE KNOW THAT SUBSTANTIVELY
YOU HAVE THE PROGRAMS THE
TECHNIQUE OF HAVING AS- OF
ACQUIRING THE MONEY IS THE
FINANCE ACTIVITY SO PLEASE
PROCEED. SO THE PROPOSAL IS AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION OF
THIRTY EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION
AND FIFTY EIGHT POSITIONS WHY
THOSE NUMBERS. IN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU SEE THAT
THERE'S A APPENDIX. THAT
APPENDIX IS A SERIES OF
ADDITIONAL DATA WE PULLED OUT
OF SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
RESULTS. THE FOCUS IS ON THOSE
TWO BIGGEST GAPS. AND THEN
THINKS ABOUT THE STAFF HOURS IN
THE MISSION HOURS RELATED TO
WHAT YOU SEE IN THIS BCP. SO
THAT THIRTY EIGHT MILLION LET'S
SEND TO THREE THINGS. HERE'S MY
FIRST MESSAGE. ANY MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME NO
REGRETS SMART INVESTMENTS AWAY
TO SHRINK YOUR GAP. CAN BE
THINGS OTHER THAN LABOR SO WE
WANT TO USE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THREE WAYS MODERNIZE
OUR HATCHERIES SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WE CAN BY
EIGHTEEN EXHORTING MACHINES AND
INCREASE OUR EFFICIENCIES ON
DEALING WITH OUR HATCHERY FISH
WE CAN BY FORTY. BY READING
SMALL THREE HATCHERY TRUCKS
WHICH ARE MORE MODERN REDUCE
OUR EMISSIONS FROM A VEHICLE
FLEET AND INCREASE THE
SURVIVABILITY OF THE FISH WERE
TAKING OUT THE WATERS FOR YOUNG
KIDS TO FISH FOR. WE'D LIKE TO
TAKE. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
MODERNIZE OUR WATER CONVEYANCE
SYSTEMS THE MANAGER WETLANDS
AND ALSO FOR NOT CONNORS HERE'S
HOW. WE WANT TO FIFTEEN
PROJECTS AND CONVERT ALL DIESEL
PUMPS TO SOLAR ARRAYS TO MANAGE
OUR PUMPS ON OUR OWN LANDS AT
SMART. IN WE WOULD LIKE TO BUY
SOME HEAVY EQUIPMENT THAT IS
MORE MODERN EQUIPMENT SHRINKS
ARE MAINTENANCE COSTS REDUCES
OUR MISSIONS IN OUR EQUIPMENT
FLEET ALLOWS US TO MANAGE OUR
WETLANDS BETTER. LAST THING WE
LIKE TO DO IS INVEST IN A PLAN
WE HAVE SEVEN PLANES IN OUR
FLEET SIX OF THEM WERE
PURCHASED IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. WITH A FIXED WING
SPECIAL CONFIGURATION PLANE. WE
CAN HAVE EYES IN THE AIR. AND
MONITOR WELLS IN THE OCEAN. AND
HELP OUR HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN CATCH CRAB IN A WAY THAT
AVOIDS MARINE MALE MAMMAL
ENTANGLEMENTS. THAT'S THE FIRST
CATEGORY ONE TIME INVESTMENT IS
NOT LABOR SMART. INVESTMENTS
FROM WHERE WE SIT. NEXT ASPECT
PROGRAM. TAKE EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION THIS IS THE
CONNECTION TO THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND MECHANISM
DISCUSSION BUT ON THE SUBSTANCE.
PUT THAT MONEY ACROSS THREE
THINGS FIRST AND INVESTMENT IN
BIODIVERSITY AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY. SEVEN POSITIONS ONE
POINT NINE MILLION WE OWN A
MILLION ACRES IN THE STATE. AND
WE MANAGE THOSE PROPERTIES. WE
WANT TO DO CLIMATE RESILIENCY
ASSESSMENTS ON THOSE PROPERTIES
BECAUSE WE THINK THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE ONE IN YOUR
DISTRICT CHAIR WHERE YOU'VE
BEEN OUT IN SEEN IF WE WERE
STORE PROPERTIES ALONG THE BAY
SHORE. WITH LOCAL PARTNERS IN
GOVERNMENT WE CAN USE OUR
WETLANDS AND OUR PROPERTIES AS
FEE LEVEL RISE BUFFER AND
ADAPTATION PROPERTY. WE THINK
THAT OPPORTUNITY EXISTS ALONG
THE COAST. ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE
ON THIS LAND BASE BUT A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO ARE NOT OUR
TRADITIONAL CUSTOMERS HUNTERS
AND ANGLERS DON'T REALIZE WE
HAVE. WE WANT TO OPEN IT UP. TO
A WHOLE NEW SWATH OF CALIFORNIA
THAT REFLECTS AN INCLUSIVE
APPROACH. TO THE USE OF OUR
LANDS IN AREAS AROUND LA AND
SAN DIEGO IN SACRAMENTO WE
THINK THAT'S A GREAT FUTURE.
THIS INVESTMENT WILL ALLOW US
TO EXPLOIT CITIZEN SCIENCE IN
INCOME TARLY DIFFERENT WAY THAN
WE CURRENTLY DO. USING TOOLS
LIKE AYE NATURALIST IN GETTING
PEOPLE OUT ON OUR PROPERTIES
HELPING US BE BOTANISTS. THE
NEXT CATEGORY CUTTING GREEN
TAPE WE'D LIKE TO TAKE FIFTEEN
POSITIONS THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND CREATE A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM. FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO OREGON AND
COASTAL STREAMS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE WE CAN ACTUALLY BRING
SALMON BACK IN THOSE WATERWAYS
WE HAVE PROGRESSIVE TIMBER
COMPANIES. PARTNERSHIPS WITH
TRIBES PROGRESSIVE WATER
AGENCIES LIKE CINEMA COUNTY AND
A SWEET A CONSERVATION GROUPS I
WANT TO PUT IN ONE PLACE
LAWYERS GRANT MAKERS PERIMETERS
PLANNERS AND GO TO SCALE AND
PACE ON RESTORATION PROJECTS BY
CUTTING THE BARRIERS WE PUT IN
THE WAY. LAST CATEGORY. MAYBE
THE MOST IMPORTANT I'VE NEVER
SEEN IT IN MY CAREER. THIRTY
ONE PEOPLE AND TEN POINT SEVEN
Mà. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
INVEST IN THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT PROGRAM.
WE HAVE ABOUT THREE FOUR FIVE
PEOPLE. WHO ARE WORKING IN THAT
WHOLE PROGRAM THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LEGALLY
PROTECTED STATE LISTED ANIMALS
AND PLANTS. JUST IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF I THINK WE'VE
GOTTEN NORTH OF THE DOZEN NEW
PETITIONS WE'VE GOT A PROCESS.
WE ARE STRUGGLING TO KEEP UP ON
THE LISTING SIDE AND WE ARE
FORGETTING ABOUT HOW DO YOU
BRING THEM BACK. WITH THAT
AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT WE CAN
ACTUALLY PUT PEOPLE LONG
COLLABORATIVE CONSERVATION SAFE
HARBOR AGREEMENTS WERE.
CONSERVATION STRATEGIES FOR
ANIMALS WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
GET TO YET LIKE MOUNTAIN LIONS
ARE BOBCATS THE THINGS WE CAN
DO WITH THAT KIND OF INVESTMENT
CHANGES THE GAME FOR US. THE
LAST ASPECT. BACK IN THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
YOU APPROVED AN AUGMENTATION OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
THIRTY POSITIONS WHILE OF THOSE
HAVE AN EXPIRED YET THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WE KNOW
ENOUGH THAT INVESTMENT PRODUCE
SUCH GOOD RETURNS GO AHEAD MAKE
IT PERMANENT. THAT'S MY PITCH.
A SALES JOB I THINK IT'S A
STRONG PROPOSAL THIS ONE I
HAVEN'T SEEN YET IN MY CAREER
IN THE NINE YEARS AS DIRECTOR
SO I'M APPRECIATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. WE
HEAR THESE RUMORS OF ALL THESE
FEDERAL WORKERS THAT USED TO
WORK ON ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE FOR
APPOINTMENTS THEY TO
CALIFORNIA. I'M LA YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THESE YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS ON
WHETHER THESE. ARE BUSTER WELL.
ADDRESSING ARE A I'M
DEFICIENCIES FOR AWHILE HARD WE
DO INDEED HAVE SOMETHING I
RACHEL A WITH THE IN OFFICE SO
AS THE AD DIRECTOR NOTED AND AT
THE TOP OF YOUR CHEN ON PAGE
ELEVEN THERE THREE COMPONENTS
OF THIS PROPOSAL SO THE FIRST
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND BASICALLY
TO. THE QUICK MEN AND INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES WE THINK THAT'S
WELL TARGETED AND TIME AND
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND HELPING TO
CLOSE THOSE GAPS THAT WERE
SHOWN AB THREE ONE TIME FUND SO
WE WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING
THAT TWENTY MILLION FOR THE
SECOND PIECE FOR THE ON GOING
WE DO THINK THE PROPOSALS- ARE
WELL TARGETED AT AT IDENTIFIED
NEEDS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
IT'S JUST THE FUNDING SOURCES
AS HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO. OUT
COMES WITH TRADE OFFS SO WE
DON'T HAVE A SILVER BULLET EASY
ANSWER FOR YOU ON THIS WE HAVE
A FEW OPTIONS ONE WOULD BE TO
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BUT THAT WOULD REQUIRE SHIFTING
FUNDING AWAY FROM THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND SO IT'S
REALLY AN ISSUE OF CONSERVATION
IT OFF YOU CAN JUST PRO RATE.
GEN FUND INSTEAD BUT AND OF
COMES WITH GENERAL FUND TRADE
OFF YOU COULD AT FIVE A POOR OF
THE PROPOSED RATHER THE FULL
NINETEEN IN IF THERE SIR HOME
AND YOU THINK FOR HIGHER
AUTHORITY AND YOU EITHER OF
SOURCE THAT CREATES LESS OF A
FUNDING TRADE OFF BUT YOU'RE
NOT CLOSING THOSE GAPS AS MUCH
AND THEN THE FOURTH OF WHICH IS
BE TO AND WAIT UNTIL. YEAR IN
YOU'VE GOT THE FORMER OF THE
SERVICE BUDGET AND THE REVENUE
ASSURANCE PREGNANCY IF OUR
OTHER FINDINGS YOU THANK YOU.
THEN. THIRTY IN OF THE PROPOSAL
WHICH ACTING NOW. TO FUNDING
FOR. YOUR PLAY ONE TO A- THE
FUNDING SHORTFALLS THAT WE KNOW
COME BECAUSE- FUNDS PROVIDED
FROM THE FOR. YEAR IN EIGHTEEN
NINETY. WOULD RECOMMEND ROOF AT
DIFFERING ACTION ON THAT UNTIL
NOW. YEAR IN THE TO. REAL NEEDS
BE MADE. I'M PART OF THE RE THE
LET. ON PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
YEARS BECAUSE YOU WANTED TO SEE
THE RESULTS OF THE SERVICE BASE
BUT- OF. MAKING A FALL ON GOING
I'M DECISION ABOUT FUNDING AND
THE PEACE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
YET OF THE ANALYSIS IS THE
MONEY PEACE WE HAVE THE SERVICE
PEACE BUT NOT THAT PIECE OF.
OUR HOW MUCH REVENUE COMES FROM
ALL THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES HOW DID THOSE PLAN WHAT
WHAT ROLE IS PAID BY RATE
PAYERS WHAT ROLES. BE PLAYED BY
THE GENERAL FUND. SO WE THINK.
THAT FULL ANALYSIS WOULD BE
HELPFUL BEFORE YOU MAY HAVE
THOSE I'M GOING DECISIONS ON ON
DRESSING UP ONLY WILL. NEED TO
BE A NEXT. YOU HAVE ANOTHER
YEAR BEFORE YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT. FINANCING TWENTY FOUR.
SINCE YOU WERE. A FRIEND THE
ASSEMBLY SITE. SOME FULL
SEARCHING PUT. YOU HAVE TO SIT
TODAY. SO RIGHT. AT MY- BUT
PAUL. ALL UP. YEAH BUT. BOTH
YOU. I KNOW. IT IS ON IT THE
GENERAL FUND. I HAVE A. IN
LOOKING AT WHAT. YOU AT. I'M
THAT I'M GOING WE ALSO LOOKED
AT WHAT IN EARLY AND WE- AND I.
MORE ME IT. YEAH NOTING THAT
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER. WE'LL
WORK IN THE IN THE YEAH. WELL
LET REASON FOR. THE OTHER. ALRP
BUT I. ANNUAL THERE'S- YEAH DO
YOU I AND NOTING THAT THAT WHEN
THE THERE KNOWLEDGE THERE'S-
YEAH. I ALL RIGHT BUT- YEAH.
AND ON THE OTHER BUILDING THE
OTHER BUILDING. YEAH FUND OWN
IT BUT WE JUST WANT TO BE. ONE
OR THE OTHER REVENUE. BUT THAT.
RIGHT AND IT BILL WOULD OUT OF
IT. IN ALL OF. YEAH WHEN IT. I
THINK THAT- AND THAT FUNDING TO
HELP OR. WORK TO BOND TALKED
ABOUT- SEA LEVEL RISE SOME
PLANNING AND OUR WETLAND AREAS
WE HAVE IN YOUR BUDGET YOU HAVE
THESE REGIONAL. I AGENCIES THAT
YOU WANNA ADD TO SET UP THE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S COME UP WITH AND
WE HAVE THESE MARKERS THESE.
THESE GROUPS THAT HAVE SOARED
ORGANICALLY SPRUNG UP I THINK
THERE'S DIFFERENT RIGHT NOW
THEY DON'T. HIT THE WHOLE.
STATE BUT THEY HAVE BASICALLY A
SERVICE PLANNING ASSISTANCE- A
PLANNING COORDINATORS TO HELP
AGENCIES COMMAND OR- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COME AND HELP THEM
WITH SOME. INFORMATION WHY
WOULD IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
DEPARTMENT IS SORT OF WORKING
WITH THAT CROWD OR OR
POTENTIALLY COULD WORK WITH
THAT CROWD I COULDN'T WHY IS
THAT NOT INCORPORATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THESE
YOU KNOW THIS SETTING UP THIS
NEW AGENCY OR THESE NEW IN THE
DEPARTMENT WE ALREADY. HAVE IN.
WHEN CONSERVATION IN A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT CLIMATE ARENAS BUT
AT. YEAH RIGHT. WATER. ALL. NO
NO I'M JUST I GET THAT IS JUST
THE PIECE THAT THAT THE FISH
WHILE IT IS GONNA DO SAME THING
SAME PLANNING DOCUMENTS SAME
THING YOU ONE LIQUID CINEMA
COUNTY OR LOS ANGELES OR SANTA
CRUZ FAME LOCALITIES SAME
COUNTY SO YOU GET IN THAT YOU
YOU YOU BRING THEM TOGETHER IT
WOULD SEEM. AS THOUGH. YOU WANT
TO DO IT YOUR WAY INSTEAD OF
THE WAY THAT. THE PUBLIC IS
SORT OF HAS RESPONDED IN THE
OUR CLIMATE CHALLENGES JUST
SOMETHING YOU MY WANT TO GO
BACK WHEN. WHEN YOU GO BOUNCE.
WE ARE DOWNSTAIRS SO WHEN YOU
GO BACK TO THE OFFICE. MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS CENTER REQUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT MISTER
CHAIR AND APPRECIATE THAT THE
ATTENTION TO THE SENATE A FEW
ITEMS BEFORE GETTING TO THE
ACTUAL FIND ITSELF FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANNA TAKE A MOMENT
TO TAKE KNOWLEDGE AT THE
DIRECTOR OF FISH AND WILDLIFE I
THINK OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
IT'S BEEN SOME OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING- IN RECENT MEMORY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. THERE HAS
BEEN- CRISIS AFTER CRISIS
WHETHER IT'S ISSUES OF CRAB
pWANTED KNOWLEDGE THE DIRECTORS
ARTWORK- IN TRYING TO BE ABLE
TO WRANGLE A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER WITH A
WIDE VARIETY OF OPINIONS. I AND
I ALSO IN GRATEFUL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT MOVING FORWARD. ON
THE SERVICE BASED BUDGETING I
THINK THAT'S GONNA ONE BE
POWERFUL FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND ALSO TO THE PUBLIC INTO
THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT DID THAT
RELY. ON A TRANSPARENT BUDGET.
IN BEING ABLE TO FOLLOW WHAT'S
BEING CHARGE WHAT'S NOT TO EACH
OF THE ACCOUNTS. I WANT TO.
FOCUS ON A WORD THAT THE
DIRECTOR USED AND I'M GONNA USE
IT IS WELL THAT'S REMARKABLE.
THANK IS REMARKABLE WE'RE BACK
HERE AFTER WE HAD MADE A DEAL
LAST YEAR EXTEND THE SUNSET FOR
TEN YEARS AND I. WE HAVE TO
KEEP IS THE HOME PLACE. AND
WHERE I HAVE FELT FRUSTRATED.
THAT MIGHT LIMITED FIVE YEARS
SINCE LEGISLATURE WHEN IT COMES
IN NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES.
I'M WE DON'T DEPEND ON THE
GENERAL FUND. WHERE TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVE FUND SOURCE. WE
DON'T DO THAT WITH MANY OTHER
DEPARTMENTS BUT WITH STATE
PARKS WITH BERMAN FISH AND
WILDLIFE THIS BUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS. IN USE THE
GENERAL FUND. SO I'LL WRAP IT
UP HERE AND SAY THIS I THINK
THE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE BEING BROUGHT FORWARD BY
THE DIRECTOR WHETHER IT'S THE
NEW AIRCRAFT THAT WILL BE
FOCUSED ON THE CRAFT LEE AND
POTENTIAL ENTANGLEMENT IT'S
JUST BE HONEST THAT'S GOING TO
KEEP THIS OUT OF ONGOING
LITIGATION- N. ESPECIALLY A-
PAIR OF THE FED'S. CRITICAL I'M
ON THE ISSUES OF THE NEW FISH
HATCHERY EQUIPMENT. THAT'S DATA
DRIVEN WE DESPERATELY NEED THAT
AND WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS
ANTIQUATED. I HAVE NO ISSUES
WITH THAT. I JUST HAVE ISSUES
WITH THE RATING OF THE EIGHT
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE. MILLION WE
EXTENDED THE SUNSET BY AN
ADDITIONAL DECADE LAST YEAR.
FIND HAS BEEN RESULTS DRIVEN IN
IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE. IN THIS
RATING IS GOING TO IMPACT
CONSERVANCY'S. IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT LOCAL AND STATE PARKS IN
HABITAT PROTECTION PROGRAMS I
THINK IT'S SHORT SIGHTED. AND I
ALSO BELIEVE IT SKIRTS THE LAW
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK. FOCUS ON THE GENERAL
FUND I DO WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO. FIND THE PROGRAMS THAT THE
DIRECTOR PARTICULARLY
HIGHLIGHTED I KNOW THAT I'M NOT
GONNA YES THEY ASK ANY
QUESTIONS- BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK THERE'S WE'RE GONNA AGREE
BUT I DO APPRECIATE PART OF
FINANCE- BRING THIS FORTY NINE.
AIR HOLDING IT OPEN TODAY
THUNDERSTORMS. RIGHT. ALLEN.
THIS. YEAH I GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF SCALE. AND THIS IS PROBABLY
A. BENCHMARKED AGAINST WHAT'S
SLIDE SIX IN THE HANDOUT RIGHT
THAT'S THE BLUE GRAPHS. OR. SO
YOU SEE NUMBERS FOUR X. THREE
X. ONE AX MEN THAT SO JUST AS A
REFERENCE POINT OUR CURRENT
EMPLOYEE BASE IS TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
EMPLOYEES. AND OUR CURRENT
PROPOSED BUDGET IS SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. HI
BUT LET'S BE HONEST. I MEAN YOU
CAN HOW WOULD YOU TAKE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION AGO FOR ACTS.
SO ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
SENATOR STERN RIGHT NOW IS THIS
KIND OF. FINISHING UP SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING. A MOMENT IN
TIME THE ANNUAL BUDGET CYCLE
DON'T ALWAYS SYNC. SO IN MY
JUDGMENT A DECISION WE
ADVOCATED AT THE DEPARTMENTS WE
KNOW ENOUGH FROM THAT FIRST
YEAR INCREDIBLE DATA SAID WE'VE
NEVER HAD. EXACTLY AND THEN YOU
OVER TIME HOPEFULLY WE BUILD A
GROUND SWELL OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE WHO REALIZE THIS IS PART
OF THEIR FUTURE ENVISIONED TO
AN I DESCRIBE A SEVENTY YEAR
JOURNEY. STARTING BACK TO AT
LEAST NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHEN
YOU RECEIVED ADVICE FROM A
NATIONAL CONSULTING FIRM. THE
PROBLEM EXISTED. YEAH. YEAH YES
A- AFTER YOU WERE. ISSUE THE.
THANK YOU. AUTHOR WATER AT.
THIS IS ABOUT. YEAH. OUR IS.
THREE EIGHT AND THAT. FIVE
FIVE. BOTTOM. ALL OF. EIGHT OUT.
YEAH. ALLEN HOW.
I AM. YEAH
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH A NUMBER
BACK. I HAD A ANOTHER. ALL I.
YEAH OUR. THIS I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE WATER. AT. AN EARLY
IF SOMEONE. ASIAN. HOW DO YOU
FIND A SERVICE CATEGORY. IT YES.
YES I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S BEACH.
YES OUT. HERE DO YOU. HAVE YES
WHAT IS THE FAILURE LOW BY IS
FAILURE WITH. WE YES SO I DON'T
THINK WE DEFINE OUR MISSION BY.
THE COST OF DOING NOTHING EVEN
THOUGH I BELIEVE THERE'S A
LEGITIMATE. COST OF DOING
NOTHING. THERE'S AN ACTUAL
DEFINITION WE USED WITHIN
SERVICE BASED PLEDGING STUFF BY
MISSION I'D LIKE A CHANCE TO
MAKE SURE I GET THE WORDS WE
USE WITH DEVOID AND SEND IT BUT
HERE'S THE SPIRIT. MISSION WAS.
LOOK AT ALL YOUR STATUTES ARE
YOUR REGULATIONS. OF ALL YOUR
POLICIES. THINK ABOUT BASS
SCIENCE RELATIVE TO ACHIEVING
THOSE ASSIGNMENTS. THINK ABOUT
THE SCALE AND SCOPE OF DOING
THIS IN A PLACE AS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA. TRY TO MAKE A
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT ON YOUR
CONSTITUENT EXPECTATIONS
RELATIVE TO ALL THOSE THINGS.
AND THEN PUSH THAT INTO THE
QUANTIFICATION OF HOW MANY
LABOR HOURS YOU WOULD NEED IF
YOU WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THAT.
YES YEAH YES I GIVE YOU A GOOD
EXAMPLE EN. I THINK IT'S ONE
THAT'S RELEVANT BUT I HOPE IT
DOESN'T COME OFF AS PANDERING.
WE HAVEN'T DONE. COMPLETED AN
ASSESSMENT OF HOW MANY M.
OUTLINES WE HAVE IN THE STATE
WE HAVE A LOT OF SCIENTIFIC A
WORK UNDER WAY DO MORE MODERN
POPULATION MODEL. THAT
POPULATION MODEL WOULD TELL US
WHAT THE POPULATION SIZE MIGHT
BE RELATIVE TO SUB POPULATIONS.
COULD BE A PATHWAYS
SCIENTIFICALLY TO UNDERSTAND
THE DIET OF THE ANIMALS IN
DIFFERENT PLACES JACK'S EX
SCIENTIFICALLY IS A WAY TO
UNDERSTAND RODENTICIDE IN OTHER
ASPECTS THAT ARECONTRIBUTING
TO MORTALITY. ONCE YOU HAVE A
POPULATION SIZE KIND OF
CREDIBLE APPROACHED
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU CAN BACK
YOURSELF INTO TRANSPORTATION
INTERFACE AND TRY TO MAP OUT
THE HOT SPOTS WHERE AN ANIMAL'S
INTERFACING WITH YOU KNOW LACK
OF WILDLIFE CORRIDORS. THAT'S
AN EXAMPLE OF ONE SPECIES THE
KIND OF. SURVEY COMMITMENT
ENERGY WE WOULD DO
SCIENTIFICALLY THAT THEN IS THE
PLATFORM FOR STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT ON HOW DO YOU LIVE
IN HABITAT WITH WILD ANIMALS
AND MANAGE YOUR TRASH. HOW DO
YOU UNDERSTAND PRE DEPLOYING. A
SUFFICIENT ASSETS TO
TRANQUILIZE ANIMALS AS PART OF
YOUR TRANS RELOCATION STRATEGY
DO YOU NEED TEN CAGES OR
HUNDRED CAGES DEPLOYED ROUNDS
HOW DO YOU ENGAGE IN. THIS THAT
OR THE OTHER THAT'S AN EXAMPLE
OF MISSION LEVEL WORK AROUND
ONE CORNERSTONE SPECIES. IF.
ALTHOUGH. MISSION AT. RELATIVE
TO IN SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
REMEMBER THAT TWO THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED TASKS. WE TOOK THESE
EIGHT SERVICE LEVELS AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT TO ACHIEVE THAT.
JACK DESERVE WHAT ARE THE TASK
GOING ON FROM. LET'S SAY PUBLIC
USE AND ENJOYMENT. ACCESS
ACCESS DAHLE EIGHTY EIGHT. WHAT
ARE THE TEMPORE DONDE. SHOULD
THE REST WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE
THAT TO THE PAPER IN THE
RESTROOM AT A TASK LEVEL. ALL
THAT IN THE ROSTER OF THREE
THOUSAND TO FIGURE OUT THE
SERVICE AREA TO GET YOU TO THE
SLIDE WHICH IS YOU JUST USING
THE LABOR OUR METRIC. IT SHOWS
YOU THE GAP. YEAH. BACK. HERE.
NOW. I DON'T. OVER. UNDER. HOW
YEAH. ONE MAYBE I. LAST I AM AS
IN. THOUSANDS. ORDER YEAH.
THANK YOU. ON. ONE ONE. YEAH.
I
KNOW THERE'S REVENUE OR I.
HOUSING IT. I AM. WORLD. I STIR
DOLLY.
ALL. I. YEAH AND YOUR.
HE ABOUT WHERE. IS IT IS IT. WE
ARE NOT. YES SO HERE'S MY
SNAPSHOT OF ONE OF THE THINGS
WILL BE. COMING BACK TO YOU
AFTER WE DO THE NEXT CLICK OF
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING. WE
HAVE AN ACCOUNT AT THE
DEPARTMENT IT'S CALLED THE
MISSION GAME PRESERVATION FUND.
IT LITERALLY IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST ACCOUNTS IN THE STATE
TREASURY I THINK IT'S NINETEEN
OH THREE NINETEEN OH NINE. IT
HAS TWO BLOCKS ONE IS WHAT WE
CALL DEDICATED THERE ARE TWENTY
NINE SUB ACCOUNTS. PEOPLE
HISTORICALLY BEEN VERY
UNTRUSTWORTHY THE DEPARTMENT AS
A STAKEHOLDER WHEN I WAS IN THE
NONPROFIT WORLD I'D COME HERE
AND SAY I WANT SOME REVENUE BUT
I WANT TO PUT IN AND A
DEDICATED ACCOUNT. SO WE'VE GOT
A WHILE PIC ACCOUNT TO DUCK
ACCOUNT. THEY ARE VERY STRICT
THEIR CONTROLLED. THE OTHER
SIDE OF THIS FUND IS NON
DEDICATED. WHAT GOES INTO THAT
ARE THE REVENUES FROM THE
ENTITLEMENT THE LICENSE THE
HUNTER AND THE ANGLER BY. AT
THE SAME TIME WE'VE GOT THIS
FUND COSTS ARE GOING UP
SALARIES APPROPRIATELY AND
WE'RE OUT OF THE GREAT
RECESSION KNOCK ON WOOD YOU
KNOW WE CAN SPEND IN WAYS WE
COULDN'T. AND THERE'S A
PERPETUAL EVERY COUPLE YEARS
YOU GET IN ABOUT. COMPOUNDED
BY. WE'RE LOSING HUNTERS AND
ANGLERS SO THERE'S LESS GOING
IN. AND IT ULTIMATELY COMES
BACK TO THE CONVERSATION YOU
BEEN HAVING WHAT'S THE
ASSEMBLAGE OF CERTAIN REVENUE
STREAMS BECAUSE NO ONE STREAM
COULD EVER CARRY THE FULL LOAD
AND IS THERE AN ADDITIVE
COMPONENT THAT HELPS YOU
ACHIEVE SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
THAT'S THE BASIC. THING THAT'S
BEEN IN DISCUSSION FOR ALL TIME
NOT BEEN DIRECTOR. WHO IS THAT
BEING ANALYZED IN THIS. YES WE
WILL START REAR IS OUT SOME
THREE YEAR PROCESS BUT IT'S NOT
IN THIS YEAR HAVE YOU SEE NOW
IS THE RAW DATA. ON JUST ARE
ARE THEY NEED FORCED LABOR IN
THE NEED NOW YOU'RE GONNA PLUG
IN THE WHAT REVENUES YOU HAVE
ON WHERE THEY COME FROM. AND
WHERE THEY'RE DEDICATED TO AND
IN THAT THAT PROCESS WILL
FINISH UP IN THIS NEXT. YEAR
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S OPEN UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER THE- THIRTEEN. ARE HAVE
A CONSERVATION FUND AND
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO N. I'M REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE- I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT WAS HAD TODAY- AND I WANT
TO JUST CLARIFY THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND DOES NOT
EXPIRE UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY ONE
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE DEAL THAT
WAS REACHED BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT IS WHAT THE
CURRENT STATUTE SAYS NOW AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK SENATOR
STERN IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE HE
CHAMPION THIS ISSUE WITH HIS
BILL AND- AS BEFORE SEVENTY
FOUR LAST YEAR AND WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE FINE WAS ABLE
TO CONTINUE. ON THROUGH TWENTY
THIRTY ONE ON WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE
ASKING THAT THE- THAT YOU
REJECT THE TRAILER BILL WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED IS ESSENTIALLY
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL AND I
THINK YOU KNOW TO PUT IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
IT'S LIKE ASKING TO SAY WELL
WE'RE NOT GOING TO PAY TO A
HIGHER AMOUNT LINE HAPPENED
INSTEAD PAVE OUTLINED BY ALL
STE BUT FRANKLY IN ORDER TO
DEAL WITH THE- YOU KNOW THE-
BIODIVERSITY DECLINE WE'RE
HAVING. TO CALIFORNIA ALL OF
THE OF. I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
IT WOULD- THE PROPOSAL WOULD
DELETE. MONEY MOVING FORWARD
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT
NOT ONLY FUNDS THE WCG BUT IT'S
MONEY THAT WOULD FUND THAT WITH
THE TAHOE CONSERVANCY THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY. STATE
PARKS AND WOULD PROVIDE- GRANTS
FOR LOCAL PARK DISTRICTS. SO
YOU KNOW THEY ARE ALSO VICTIMS
OF THIS PROPOSAL. AND FOR THE
W. C. B. PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BEING PROPOSED TO BE. AT THAT'S-
I KNOW DOLLARS THAT GO TO
ACQUIRE ABOUT LION HABITAT. OAK
WOODLANDS RIPARIAN HABITAT. AND
FOR MY FRIENDS THAT WORK IN
THE- WHAT MIGRATORY. BIRD IN
THE WATER FOUL WORLD. THAT CUTS
THE FUNDS THE INLAND WETLANDS
PROGRAM WHICH IS CRITICAL AS
PART OF THEIR WORK WITH THE
CENTRAL VALLEY JOINT VENTURE.
SO THESE ARE ALL PROGRAMS THAT
NEED TO BE CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED. AND WOULD REALLY BE
INJURED BY YOU KNOW THIS
PROPOSAL. I WOULD ALSO NOTE.
THAT IT IS ACTUALLY
ANTITHETICAL TO THE ENTIRE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING EFFORT
TO HAVE COME. TO THE PROPOSAL
LIKE THIS. BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE
THEY SAYING WILL BE JUST GONNA
SHIFT. IN POINT NINE DOLLARS
FOR THIS COMING FISCAL YEAR.
BUT THEN THEY'RE GONNA CUT THE
REST THE- FUNDING TOGETHER. IT
IS ABSOLUTELY CRAZY. WAS
SOMETHING. AND ASSEMBLY THAT
MONEY. INTO THE FIND. MAY OR
MAY NOT. TURN TO PAR. ONE LATE.
FOR THERE'S A- TURN. AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH THE DEPARTMENT THEY
ARE. USUALLY LAST LINE
FORGETTING. CHEN FUND. AND
WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT I'M ALSO.
ABOUT THE- AT W. B. AND THE
FACT THAT A BUNCH OF MONEY SO
THEY CAN JUST YOU KNOW PROP UP
THE MONEY THE FUNDS THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SEND MONEY TO
THROUGH THE H. C. F. I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE W. CD'S. CF
FIND IS SPENT ACT. EVERY YEAR
IT'S NOT THAT'S NOT MONEY THAT
SITS AROUND THAT'S MONEY THAT
CRANKS OUT VERY QUICKLY AND
GOES TO THE AREAS THAT NEED IT
AND A LOT TIMES AREAS THAT
DON'T BENEFIT FROM BOND
FUNDING. BUT FRANKLY. I'M LIKE
NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE AND
NOT SOME OF THE MORE RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE. AND SO I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST ASK IS
ALSO- SO REJECT THE TRAILER
BILL BUT HOLD OPEN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET. I WOULD
AGREE THE ONE TIME FUNDING THAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. THE EXTENSION OF THE
THIRTY MILLION THAT WAS
PROMISED DURING THE LAST BUDGET
DEAL VERY IMPORTANT. EIGHTEEN
TWO POINT NINE MILLION FOR THE
THREE PROGRAMS THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS TO. I
COULDN'T SIT HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND TELL YOU. THE
THIRTY ONE NEW POSITIONS. AT
THE IN ANY DANGER SPECIES
PROGRAM WOULDN'T BE IMMENSELY
BENEFICIAL. FOR LOTS OF THINGS
THAT WE WORK ON WOLVES. THE
AMOUNT LINES IF THEY'RE LISTED.
ALL OF THEM AND MANY OTHER
SPECIES THAT ARE LISTED NOW OR
ARE GOING TO NEED TO BE LISTED
IN THE FUTURE. WE NEED THOSE
BIOLOGISTS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY. RIGHT NOW THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ONLY FIVE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE CATERED 100%
WORKING IN DANGER SPECIES
PROGRAM. WHICH IS CRAZY WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THESE ARE PROGRAMS. THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED THAT SHOULD
BE AUGMENTED. THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND IS NOT THE
PLACE TO BE LOOKING FOR THE
FUNDING. THANK YOU. TAX GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
LION FOUNDATION AND I. I WANT
TO START BY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR STERN AND
THE DIRECTOR- IN RELATION TO A
SERIES OF- SIGNIFICANT MOUNTAIN
LION- ISSUES THAT HAVE.
CATAPULTED AND TO THE PUBLIC'S
CONCERN OVER THE LAST MONTH OR
SO AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
BOTH OF THEM FOR. THEIR
ENGAGEMENT AND THERE ARE. THE
POLICY CHANGES IN THE RESPONSE
THAT'S BEEN SWIFTER THAT I HOPE
WE DEEPLY HOPE AT THE MOUNT
LINE FOUNDATION ARE GOING TO
PUT MOUNT LANDS ON A PATH TO.
DECREASE MORE BUT HE AN
INCREASE LEGAL PROTECTIONS- AND
AS THE- IN A POP WHEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH CREE. THE HABITAT. FUND
I'LL I'LL SECOND KIM'S REMARKS
ABOUT THE VALUE OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THAT FUND
MAKES- PARTICULARLY FOR
MOUNTAIN LIONS. BUT I WANT TO
URGE REJECTION ON LEGAL GROUNDS
I'M CONCERNS AS THE DRAFTERS OF
THE MEASURE. THAT AMENDMENTS
ARE REQUIRED PURSUANT TO THE
MEASURE TO FURTHER THE PURPOSE
AND INTENT. OF THE PROPOSITION
WHICH WE WOULD SUBMIT. RATING
TAKING AWAY THE FUND- DOES NOT
SERVE THAT THE LANGUAGE OF THE
INITIATIVE ONLY ALLOWS FOR
EXTENDING REPEALING THE END
DATE. OF THE FIND IT DOES NOT
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR ELIMINATING
IT- AS PROPOSED IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. AND FINALLY OF
THOSE WEREN'T SUFFICIENT LEGAL
CONCERNS WE DO BELIEVE THIS
WOULD AT A MINIMUM TRIGGERING
FOR FIFTY VOTE- TO CHANGE HIS
VOTE. OVER BY THEN IT AS-
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE ON A PATH TO
APPROVING THAT I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE YOU LEGAL BACK. BACK FOR
THAT DECISION THE GUARDS. I
MYSELF WEARING WEARING THEIR
TIME OF AN LED HAVOC. AND A- IN
BOTH VISION. OF EARLY TO TENS.
THAT WAS TRIGGERED BY A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HUFF LET. AND
THE SP BE EFFORT HAVE BEEN
FULLY UP PARTICIPATING AND I AM
HEARTENED. AS OTHERS ARE BY THE
DEPARTMENTS EMBRACE AND
COMMITMENT TO THE SERVER SPACE
BUDGET EFFORT. AND THAT
PRELIMINARY INFORMATION IS OF
COURSE SUPER CONSISTENT WITH
OUR LONG TIME EXPERIENCE OF
UNDERFUNDED MISS. BUT THE REAL
PROMISE OF THE SERVICE BASE
BUDGET IS TO BE ABLE TO KERN
CREDIBLY SUBSTANTIATE AND
QUANTIFY THE UNMET NEEDS. SO
THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH
NOTHING LESS THAN THE
TRANSFORMATION. IN THE WAY THAT
WE FUND FISH AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION BE OF DEEPLY UNDER
INVESTED AND WE NEED THE S. P.
TOOL TO GUIDE US SO. WITH
RESPECT TO THE RAMS THAT ARE.
FIGHTING THE B. C. P. LAYOUT
YOU KNOW THERE ARE CLEARLY
WITHIN THAT SEVEN BUT- BEING A-
CAREFUL TO TIE THOSE. TWO THE
SPACE BUT IT NOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THE
FUTURE. TO COME BACK HERE AND
MAKE A CASE I'M CONNECTED TO
THAT SO I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
AND- RISE. ON THE JUST LATER
THE MINISTRY IN THE DEPART FINE.
AN THE COLD THE PEOPLE OF. TO
BE ADVISED NAY RACING CAN LIFT
UP THE NEXT FEW. THANK YOU. CAN
THEY'RE CAUGHT STATION A CHAIN
I KNOW IS AWESOME YEAH I KNOW
EVERY THIS IS A OPPORTUNE OUR
FIRST TIME AND TO. AND I PEOPLE
PRETTY GOOD FLATTERED HERE IN I
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE. INFO ON
YOUR NONPROFIT IN THAT'S BUT IF
WE CAN FOCUS ON ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN. FIVE THE CHAIR THAT
WOULD PLEASE THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THAT OTHER
THAN THE BEHALF OF THE NATURE.
CAN PLAN SIDE TREND LIMITED CAL
TROUT. IN A DUPE ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CHAIRS- WILLINGNESS AND
PRIOR HEARINGS TO ALLOW ME TO
COULD TOOK ON A LITTLE FURTHER
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
REALLY FINE POINT ON SOMETHING
THAT WAS MENTIONED BY FINANCE.
WITH REGARD TO THE OTHER
CATEGORIES THE STATE PARKS
BECAUSE THE CONSERVANCY TAHOE
ITS CENTER BUT DO YOU RECEIVE
MONEY FROM FROM THE H. C. F. AS
WELL. IT JUST SO HAPPENS THAT
THE GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION
RIGHT NOW CLOSELY MIRRORS THE
ALLOCATION TO GO TO W. CB.
THERE IS NO STATUTORY THE GIVEN
TO BAT FUNDING COMING FROM
GENERAL FUND AS OPPOSED
EVERYTHING ELSE. AND I ALSO
WANT TO HELP BUT IN PROP ONE
SEVENTEEN THERE WAS REFERENCES
TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE
PLATE ON FISHING AND
PRESERVATION FUN IN A COUPLE OF
OTHER FUN SORT IS. THAT NO
LONGER PROVIDE MONEY TO THE H.
C. F. SO. MYSTERY AND WONDER
INVESTING FROM THAT SOURCE. IS
THAT. EVIDENCED BY IN PRIOR
YEARS BEING SEEING THOSE
REDUCTIONS TAKE PLACE FOR THE
H. C. F. CERN'S. PART BECAUSE
OF THE SEA IN ADDITION TO THE
B. C. B. STILL STAND AND WE
HAVE NO FAITH BUT NEXT YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WON'T
COME BACK AND SAY HEY WE CAN
TAKE THAT MONEY AND- MOVE IT
ELSEWHERE AS WELL. THAT SAID
AND DID ALL MEN'S MADE FENDERS
WILDLIFE AND MOUNT ONE
FOUNDATION- WE'D WE DO
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS OF THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN- ENGAGING IN TO REALLY PUT
THE DEPARTMENT. AND THE BEST
FOOT MOVING FORWARD. AND WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS IN THE PROPOSAL
THAT MEN HAVE BEEN OUTLINED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. X. X. AS CHAIR MEMBERS
PAT MORAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTIST I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY YOU-
BUT WE DO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
IN AS MUCH THAT IT PROVIDES
FIFTY EIGHT POSITIONS. FORTY
ONE OF THOSE OUR STATE
SCIENTIFIC POSITIONS POSITIONS
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO FULFILL ITS
MANDATE. THOUGH I KNOW YOU'RE
HOLDING THIS OPEN BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU REACH AN
AGREEMENT ON THIS WE CERTAINLY
HOPE. THAT YOU MAINTAIN THE
FUNDING FOR THOSE POSITIONS
THANK YOU. ANNETTE MEET ON A
WITHOUT A CAL. THE WHOLE HARD
SO. THE CONTENT. OF THE
PROPOSAL WE DON'T AGREE WITH
THE FUND SOURCE. WE HAVE SEEN.
CRIME OVER TIME. THE NATURAL
RESOURCES SECTOR BEING UNDER
FUNDED CONSTANTLY OVER AND OVER
AND OVER- YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF
LOOKING AT. HAVING A CLIMATE
CATALYST WHEN WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT A CLIMATE BIO
DIVERSITY FUND TAKING SOME OF
THE GENERAL FUND MONEY THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED AND BEING
INVESTED INTO NATURALRESOURCES
WE HAVE WE HAVE THE MONEY
FINANCE. SOMEHOW FINDS MONEY TO
FIND. SOMETHING FOR CATALYST
FUNDS FROM THE GENERAL FUND WHY
NOT NATURAL RESOURCES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS. ECHO IN
A LINE MY COMMENTS FOR THOSE OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS I THINK
I'LL JUST- ECHO WAIT TENER
MCGUIRE SAID WE MADE A DEAL
LAST YEAR TO EXPAND THIS FONG
THROUGH LEGISLATION THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. WE SHOULD HONOR
THAT COMMITMENT- THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA POINT OUT THAT I
HAVE THAT SAME CUP AT HOME THAT
YOU DO MISTER CHAIR. SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS CHAMPIONSHIP.
NEXT GOOD MORNING PAUL MASON
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST I'LL BE
BRIEF AS ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
THE FIRST THREE COMMENTS I
THOUGHT THOSE WERE ABSOLUTELY
ON POINT AND JUST ADD THAT THE
IDEA IS THAT WE WOULD CONDITION
THE ABILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT
TO MEET THEIR STATUTORY AND
PUBLIC TRUST RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR WILDLIFE PROTECTION
CONSERVATION ON ELIMINATING ONE
OF THE ONLY STABLE SOURCES OF
CONSERVATION FUNDING IT'S JUST
MADNESS. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING A PUBLIC GARCIA WITH
ENVIRONMENT DEFENSE FIND WHAT.
PEDRO SAID WE AGREE WITH. THE
MORNING MORNING CAN I BEHALF OF
MIDLAND SLIGHT REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION I'M ALSO
DISTURBED RATE COMMENTS OF PAT
SPEAKERS ABOUT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SHIFT IN THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT
OPPOSED TO THE SHIFT AS
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS OF SAID THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RELIEF
CINEMA LAND TRUST AS WELL AS-
LATINO OUTDOORS WE WANT TO ECHO
A LOT OF THE SAME COMMENTS
ABOUT THE FRUSTRATION AND THE
FUN SHIFT. BUT FOR LATINO
OUTDOORS IN PARTICULAR WE ALSO
WANTED TO RAISE THAT ALTHOUGH
WE DISAGREE WITH THE SOURCE OF
FUNDING WE DO APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION ON OUR REGION
EDUCATION. AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO THAT
I'M PARTICULARLY FOR DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES FROM OTHER SOURCES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. WE
WILL HOLD THIS MATTER MOVING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN LINKS
RUFUS. IN NON GAME SPECIES GO
AHEAD DIRECTOR. THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS TO EMPLOYMENT LAW
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FOUR.
IT WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
WITH THREE POSITIONS AND ABOUT
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
TO COMPLETE THE FIRST DESIGN
AND POPULATION ASSESSMENT A
MONITORING PROGRAM OF OUR
BOBCAT POPULATION. THAT'S
SIMPLE LA AREA REPORT NO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
FINANCE. MEMBERS MEISTER DOLLY.
CAN I KNOW THE LEGISLATION THAT
WAS PASSED THAT WAS ABOUT
HUNTING AND TRAPPING SO WHAT
WHAT IS THIS MONEY TO BE SPENT
FOR AND WHAT DO YOU TRY IT
WHAT'S THE GOAL. WELL IT IS
GOING TO BE. THE DIRECTIVE IN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FOUR.
WHICH SAYS UPON FUNDING
DEPARTMENT SHALL DO THIS
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT A
MONITORING PLAN THAT IS ALSO
RELATED TO A DIFFERENT PART OF
THIS IN THE BILL TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR. WHICH SAYS THERE'S NO
HUNTING OF BOB UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. UNLESS AND UNTIL.
SUCH AN ASSESSMENT IS DONE THE
ASSESSMENT IS BROUGHT BACK TO
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
GOES THROUGH A SUITE OF PUBLIC
PROCESS SEES. DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T BE
HUNTING. OKAY. UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE A BOBCAT QUESTION. I WOULD.
BUILDING ON SENATOR DOLLIES
QUESTION. ARE YOU REALLY SORT
OF FOCUSING IN ON THE UNLESS
AND UNTIL HERE AND SPEEDING UP
THAT PART OF IT LIKE WHAT
WHAT'S THE- WHAT'S THE NEAR
TERM WHAT'S THE RUSH NEAR TERM
IN YOUR MIND TO PRIORITIZE THIS
KIND OF EFFORT. WELL WE'VE GOT.
NOT A NOT A- COMPLETE
MORATORIUM BUT AT LEAST TO HAVE
A PRETTY CLEAR SIGNAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE I'M JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW. THIS FITS IN. EACH
YEAR THE DEPARTMENT GETS
TYPICALLY A SWEET A NEW
MANDATES. SOMETIMES THEY COME
WITHOUT THE FUNDING TO COMPLETE
THE ASSIGNMENT. THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE. I SUPPOSE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THERE IS A
PERMANENT MORATORIUM BUT THE
BILL IS MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT IN OUR JUDGMENT I RESPECT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
DECIDE NOT TO FUND THIS BUT FOR
OUR PURPOSES LOOKING AT THE
MOST RECENT ASSIGNMENTS WE
THANK YOU THINK YOU'RE LEGALLY
COMPELLED TO DO THIS. OR IN IS
IT IS IT IT'S MORE
DISCRETIONARY IF YOUR GROUP
GREAT QUESTION. I'D LIKE A
CHANCE TO READ THE STATUTE WITH
THAT QUESTION IN MY MIND.
CONSULT WITH OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL OFFICE AND GET BACK TO
YOU. OKAY SO THAT'S WHERE I WAS
HEADED WE HAD. I WAS ON THE
COMMITTEE WHEN THEY TALKED
ABOUT THE REVENUE FOR THE TAGS
WE DIDN'T MEET DE AMOUNT IT WAS
COSTING US TO. UPON THAT THE
PROGRAM THAT WAS ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS I ACTUALLY VOTED
AGAINST THIS BILL. BUT I WAS
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT THERE
WASN'T. HUNTING ANYMORE AND ARE
OR- SO WHAT WAS SO DO YOU THIS.
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO ALMOST
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING
TO. FIND OUT WHETHER WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HOT OR NOT.
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBERS OF THE
POPULATION NOW. THIS INVESTMENT
WE'LL FIND OUT WHAT WE HAVE AS
THE BOBCATS HOW MANY WHERE
HEALTH RISKS RED STABILITY
INSTABILITY IT'S AN ASSESSMENT
OF ALL THOSE POPULATION
DYNAMICS. WE WOULD PRESENTED TO
OUR COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO START
HUNTING ON IT OR NOT. BASED ON
THIS ASSEMBLY BILL. WE HAVE AN
ASSIGNMENT AS I READ THE
STATUTE TO COMPLETE THE STUDY
UPON START ACTING HONOR START
HUNTING ON IF HE SAID. THAT'S
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR IS. ALL
RIGHT HOW. AND YOUR QUESTION
BEEN ANSWERED. OKAY SO THIS IS
THIS IS A REQUEST FOR FUNDING
TWO OR THREE POSITIONS FOR THE
STATE WIDE MONITORING PLAN TO
ASSESS THE BOBCAT POPULATION
CORRECT. SENATE STERN. I WOULD
JUST I APPRECIATE- THE CHAIR
WANTS TO DO HERE I THINK. GIVEN
ALL THE OTHER RESOURCE
CONSTRAINTS I THINK IT IS.
WORTH CONSIDERATION OF WHETHER
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY. NECESSARY
WAY I READ THE LAWS THERE'S
DISCRETION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT TO UNDERTAKE THIS
ACTION I DON'T SEE THIS IS
PARTICULARLY URGENT AT THE
MOMENT. BUT YEAH I'M OPENED
HOWEVER WE WANT TO PROCEED YOU
ARE YOU YOU'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
YOUR FOLKS AND TRY TO GET US
ALL UP ON YOUR QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW IF WE CAN BE DEFERRED TO
ANOTHER IF IT UPCOMING AGENDA
TO. TAKE ANOTHER LOOK OR- HE
WON APPROACH BUT I WOULD LOVE
THAT. LET'S HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC ANYBODY HERE ON ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN THIS IS THE
STATE WIDE BOBCAT MANAGEMENT
PLAN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION I DID
HAVE PREPARED REMARKS WOULD
BASED ON THE CONVERSATION I
JUST WANTED TO COME UP AND
SPIEGEL. ON THIS ISSUE SO WE
WERE PART OF THE COALITION LAST
YEAR THAT OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WE BELIEVE.
THAT THESE DECISIONS ARE BEST
TO REMAIN VESTED WITH THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION. THERE
VESTED WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT GAME
SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT I'M
NOT STAYING HERE TO SAY YOU
KNOW I'M DEFENDING THIS OR THE
OTHER I HAVE NO INTEREST IN
HUNTING BOBCAT AND WATER FELL
WITHIN THE CLIENTS- BUT THERE
ARE SOME THAT DO. AND THERE'S A
BODY THAT'S APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR IT WORKS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON THE BASIS OF
SCIENCE TO HELP MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS. THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THE FIRST TIME LAST YEAR REMOVE
THAT STORY FROM THEM WITH THIS
BILL BUT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SO.
PROCESS IN GENERAL. AS WE WENT
THROUGH THE DOOR ON THIS BILL.
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT WE WERE
NOT GOING TO DO THE SCIENCE
FIRST. AND THEN TALK ABOUT
WHETHER BàN WAS APPROPRIATE
WE'RE GOING TO DO A BAND. AND
THEN TRY TO FOLLOW AT THE
SCIENCE SO WE SEE THIS AS- A
LOGICAL CONCLUSION TO THE WAY
THAT THE CHAIR OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MR
PORTANTINO ALLOW THE BILL TO
MOVE THROUGH HIS COMMITTEE AT
THE END OF THE YEAR. SO WE
WOULD ASK. THAT YOU APPROVE THE
FUNDING SO THAT THE SCIENCE CAN
BE DOWN AGAIN WE WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE PROCESS WAS DONE.
BACKWARDS DOT NET SIGN SHOULD
BE THE REASON WHY IN THE
JUSTIFICATION WHY GAMES.
MANAGEMENT IS CHANGING THE- SO
CAN YOU WONDER WHY IS
CALIFORNIA WATER FELL IF YOU'RE
MAKING A COMMENT. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE SOMEBODY
PROPOSED TO BAN DOVE HUNTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN NATION IN
TWO THOUSAND AND THREE IN RIGHT
SO THERE ARE THESE DECISIONS
AND DISCUSSIONS THAT TAKE
PLACE. THAT CAN IMPACT SOME OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S OWN PRIORITIES
RELATIVE TO OUR THREE THEY WANT
TO GET MORE PEOPLE. FISHING AND
HUNTING BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT IN THE FIRST ITEM THAT YOU
CHATTED ABOUT- SO AGAIN WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BE HAPPY TO HAVE ANY OFF
LINE CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. WE'LL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING IS SIR STAFFORD
CONDITION IS TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGET THE CHAIR IS. LEAVES
IT'S APPROPRIATE I IN THE
REMARKS THAT WERE MADE WE DO A
LOT OF LEGISLATION THAT DOESN'T
PROVIDE FUNDING I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE US WITH THE-
INFORMATION AND- WHAT'S THE
BOBCAT POPULATION LOOKS THAT'S
WHY WOULD BE REMAKE. AMENDING
AND I BY SURE DOLLY- WITH THOSE
REMARKS I'M GONNA CHANGE MY I
WAS GONNA VOTE NOW BUT I'M
GONNA HAVE SUPPORTERS BECAUSE I
DO THINK IT IS BACKWARDS AND I
THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE THATWE
LEGISLATE BY MOTION NOT BY FAX.
MOTION B GUYS SEND REQUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ACCOUNTS
KING I NOT ONLY. WHERE RUNNING
TURN. YEAH MATTER OPEN AND
LOOKS AT SOME PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN DEADLY FORCE TRAINING
THIS IS FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION CAL FIRE IN PARKS
AND RECREATION. THIS RESERVE
MOBILE. TRAINING SIMULATORS AND.
TRUCKS TO MOVE THOSE ARE
VEHICLES TO MOVE THOSE. PLEASE
PROCEED. SURE HE'S MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING. MY NAME IS DAVID BASS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND I'LL LET MY
TWO PARTNERS HERE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES. SCOTT ELLIOTT A
DEPUTY CHIEF OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
EMERGENCY SERVICES OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. HEY
GOOD MORNING CHEN CUNNINGHAM
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR FIRE
PROTECTION OPERATIONS OF WHICH
IS OUR CALPERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROGRAMS. SO THIS JOINT
PROPOSAL WITH FROM RESOURCES
AGENCY THAT INCLUDES OUR THREE
DEPARTMENTS FISH AND WILDLIFE
STATE PARKS AND CAL FIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIVISIONS. OUR
DRESSING OUR COLLECTIVE
TRAINING NEEDS THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT TO MEET
THE MANDATED LEGISLATIVE INTENT
OF AB THREE NINETY TWO AND SB
TWO THIRTY. NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCIES COMBINED LAW
ENFORCEMENT STAFF IS THE SECOND
LARGEST POLICE FORCE IN OUR
STATE WITH TWELVE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO SWORN PEACE OFFICERS. IT IS
IMPERATIVE WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE MOST CURRENT
RELEVANT AND REALISTIC TRAINING
AVAILABLE THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ALLOW US TO TRAIN OUR CURRENT
STAFF AS WELL AS NEW RECRUITS.
IN THE TACTICS OF DE ESCALATION
ENGAGING WITH CONSTITUENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND UTILIZING THE
USE OF FORCE MODEL IN ALIGNMENT
WITH POST GUIDANCE. WITH THE
UTILIZATION OF THE SIMULATORS
INCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSAL OUR
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
TRAIN OUR OFFICERS TO THE NEW
STANDARD WHEN CONSIDERING A
FORCE OPTION. ALL OF OUR
COMBINED AGENCY TOTAL OF TWELVE
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO PEEPS PEACE
OFFICERS WILL NEED TO BE.
RETRAINED REGARDING USE OF
FORCE. IN ADDITION THE ITEMS IN
THE PROPOSAL WILL GIVE US THE
TOOLS NEEDED TO HAVE A
CONTINUOUS COLLABORATIVE AND
EFFICIENT TRAINING MODEL IN THE
RESOURCES AGENCY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIVISIONS ACROSS
OUR THREE DEPARTMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY COLLECTIVELY THE
BUDGET ASK IT THE ASK IS SIX
POSITIONS. THREE POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AN ON GOING TO IMPLEMENT
THE TRAINING A POLICY
COMPONENTS RELATED TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT USE OF DEADLY FORCE
PURSUANT TO THE STATUTES. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES A ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR TRAINING RESOURCES
TO BE SHARED AMONG OUR THREE
DEPARTMENTS. A STATIONARY LIVE
FIRE TRAINING SIMULATOR WILL BE
HOUSED WITH CAL FIRE INTO
MOBILE TRAINING SIMULATORS ONE
EACH FOR STATE PARKS AND FOR
FISH AND WILDLIFE. PERCENT OR
IS THAT A GOOD I JOIN. JOINT I
WAS A SALAMI ASK WHEN YOU'RE
YOU'RE SWORN OFFICERS HAVE
TRAINING RIGHT NOW DON'T THEY
GO TO A FACILITIES STATE
FACILITY AND GET OPPOSE
TRAINING THAT THEY THAT THEY-HAVE A CONTINUING POST TRAINING.
YES WE DO QUARTERLY BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE SIMULATIONS TRADE YOU
KNOW SIMULATOR FOR SIMULATIONS
TRAINING CURRENTLY RIGHT IN THE
SO THE QUESTION IS THAT. WHEN
WE'VE ADDED ANOTHER LAYER OF
FIVE HAVE. SCHOOLING THAT WE
WANT PEOPLE HAVE ON DEADLY
FORCE WHY COULDN'T THAT BE
ACHIEVED IN. THE CLASSROOM
SETTING. PLEASE GOOD QUESTION
SURE- SO IF YOU LOOK AT IT LIKE
AN ACADEMY SETTING WHERE WERE
EITHER GETTING IT THROUGH A
LECTURE MOSTLY THROUGH A
LECTURE MAHLER WRITTEN MATERIAL
INACADEMY SAID HE SETTING WE
ALSO HAVE WHAT WE CALL SCENARIO
BASED TRAINING WHERE WE TAKE
PEOPLE OUT INTO THE FIELD
ACTUALLY PUT THEM AND TRY TO
REPLICATE SCENARIOS TO PUT
THROUGH WHAT THEY MIGHT
ACTUALLY ENCOUNTER IN THE FIELD.
THIS THESE SIMULATORS WOULD
ALLOW US TO DO THAT ANY USE OF
FORCE MODEL. WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY ARE GOING OUT.
SIMULATED THROUGH A CONTACT HOW
TO USE OF FORCE DECISION TO
MAKE WHERE THEY HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT SOME DECISION MAKING
AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY USE
THEIR SERVICE WEAPON IN THE USE
OF FORCE AN OREO. WHAT ARE OUR
SISTER AGENCIES DOING ON THE
SLOT ON THE EDUCATION OF YOU
SOME FOR SOMETHING YOU SEE H.
P. AND I GET IT THERE ARE SOME.
I'M THINKING OF EUREKA WRITING
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF YOUR PEOPLE
THERE AND THE C. H. P. AND
STATE AGENTS THAT ARE UP THERE
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH. THE
TRAINING PROPRANOLOL ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO CAL FIRE SIMULATORS HAD ONLY
FOR CAL FIRES. EMPLOYEES. YES
OUR EMPLOYEES- AS PART OF THEIR
CORLEY TRAIN FOR INSTANCE IN
EUREKA I DO HAVE SOME VERY
LIMITED ACCESS TO SOME REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER THE COMPETITION
FOR TIME WTHIN THOSE REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER FOR THINGS LIKE
SIMULATORS. HIS HIGH AS WE ROLL
THIS OUT IT'S NOT SO MUCH A
SIMULATOR OR WERE PROPOSAL WE%
HAVE ALTHOUGH IT IS A PORTION
OF THE FIRST YEAR FUNDING. IT'S
A TRAINING PROCESS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH. FOLKS TRADITIONALLY
LEARN BY LISTENING SEEN AND
THEN DOING THE TRAINING
SIMULATORS ALLOW AS TO THE
REPETITION IN A TIME SAVINGS.
FASHION WE CAN SET UP THE
SCENARIOS RUNNING NEXT RECETA
FROM THE STEREO. SB SO BY
HAVING THE DEDICATED TRAIN
AMONGST OUR THREE AGENCIES WERE
ALLOWED TO FOCUS ON THAT AND
WE'RE LED TO FOCUS ON THAT
SPECIFIC TO OUR MISSION AND OUR
UNIQUE WORKING CONDITIONS WHICH
ALL THREE OF A SHARE COMPARED
TO MAYBE A WORKING CONDITION
FROM- MEANS OUT MUNICIPALITY OR
COUNTY. I GUESS THE QUESTION IS
SAID YOU KNOW I'M I'M HAVE SOME
BIAS HERE I HAVE SOME BY AS
THEY THINK THE EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE IS A URBAN CITY. ROBIN
BECAUSE THAT'S WE SEE IT I DO I
DON'T REMEMBER THE- FISHERMEN
AT BEING CONFRONTED WITH
FISHING GAME IN A EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE SAID I'M SURE IT MUST
HAPPEN IN THERE. IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S JUST NOT NOT
REPORTED SO I III. I UNDERSTAND
THE STATUTE REQUIRES TRAINING
FOR EVERYBODY I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS THAT IT LOOKS AS
THOUGH I HAVE THREE SIMULATORS.
FOR THREE DEPARTMENTS AND WE
TAKE CARE OF THE WHOLE SO HERE.
IS THERE IS THERE ECONOMY OF
SCALE THAT. THE H. P. IN EUREKA
WHERE YOU HAVE YOUR SIMILAR
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET THEIR
TRAINING THERE OR THE SAID THE
COOPERATION BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES. OR IS SEVEN FIVE AND
FOR IT HAVE SIMULATORS FOR
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WANTS AND A NEW SHINY
SIMILAR IN MAINE I'M I GET IT
THAT WE HAVE TO DO THE IN. THE
EDUCATION BUT BUT WE WANT TO BE.
CAREFUL ON HOW WE THAT
EXPENDABLE. THE FUN SO THAT'S I
GUESS THAT'S ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS ON THE WE HAVE AN
ANSWER NOW IS IF. IF ALL OF A
SUDDEN KNOCK KNOCK HEALDSBURG
SAYS I WANT TO USE CAN WE USE
OUR SIMILAR EXES ARE GUYS HE TO
HAVE. A TRAINING AND YES IT MAY
HAVE THE FISHERMEN IN THERE BUT
IT'S JUST SEND ESSENTIALLY IS
THE SAME USE OF FORCE.
REQUIREMENT FROM MS WEBER AND-
CENTER COUPLE EUROS. I HAD
LEGISLATION IS IT TRANSIT-
REUSABLE RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S IT
IT'S ONLY SIMULATIONS ONLY IN
EDUCATION RIGHT. DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE IT'S- YES MISTER DOES SO
ON BEHALF OF MY DEPARTMENT I
WOULD SAY WE ALWAYS WOULD WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. NO
CURRENTLY THERE'S APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY THOUSAND POLICE OFFICERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
AGENCIES SO. CHIEF CUNNINGHAM
IS CORRECT THERE'S GONNA BE A
LOT OF DEMAND. TO PUT PEOPLE
THROUGH THE SIMULATION TRAINING
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
MOST CURRENT STATE OF THE ART
THE BILL TO SIMULATE AND GET
THEM UP TO SPEED ON. THIS NEW
USER FOR STANDARD. BUT I SURE
DOLLY OUR- IN THE AT. BUT. ONE
STATION. IN THE REPORT IT. ABLE
TO UTILIZE THOSE. THERE'S BILL
ANY. THAT. ONE NUMBER ONE OR
SPENT THERE ARE. THESE YEAH
HELLO YOU DO YOU AGREE THAT
THIS IS RIGHT SIZE FOR THE
TWELVE HUNDRED SWORN OFFICERS
IN THESE THREE AGENCIES YEAH WE
LOOKED AT THIS AND DIDN'T HAVE
ANY MAJOR CONCERNS AND- WE WERE
HEARTENED BY THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE COMING FORTH TOGETHER
WITH ONE B. C. B. WITH THE
THREE AGENCIES AND HAVE A PLAN
ALREADY TO TRY AND SHARE THE
RESOURCES AT LEAST ACROSS THESE
THREE YOUR POINT THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING BEYOND IS WELL TAKEN
BUT FOR STARTING WITH THREE
THAT'S A GOOD START TO BOTTOM.
THIS CHAIR IS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS. OUR
WILDLIFE OFFICERS ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION. I HAD NO IDEA WHAT IT
WOULD BE COMING FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO HAD A
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS. THESE OFFICERS HAVE
DEPLOYED IN CRISIS INCIDENTS AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER INCIDENCES. ARE
SWORN TO ENFORCE ALL OF THE-
CRIMINAL CODE IN THE STATE
BEYOND JUST FISHING GAME. I AS
DIRECTOR WANT THEM FULLY
TRAINED ON USE OF FORCE AND I
ALSO ONE IS DEALING WITH
IMPLIED BIAS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE AFFECTING. POLICING IN
THE MODERN ERA SO I APPRECIATE
YOU ENTERTAINING THIS PROPOSAL.
BY SURE DOLLY NO I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THE- FUNDING UP
THE TRAINING BUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION ON THE- THE FACILITY
THERE OR THE MOBILE TRAINING.
SO IS THIS. FOR LIKE FIRE OR IS
THIS FOR LIKE ACTIVE SHOOTER
TYPE THING. BECAUSE I WITH A SO
I KNOW THAT THERE'S THEIR
STATIONED ALL OVER THE ONES
THAT ACTUALLY THEY HAD WHEN I
HEAR ON THAT THE FIREFIGHTERS
HAD WHEN I HEAR THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY. AS LEGISLATORS GOING
IS THAT IS THAT THE KIND OF
DEVICES OR IS THIS LIKE WHAT I
SAW. AT THE CHP ACADEMY WHERE
THEY HAVE YOU KNOWS THEY HAVE A
SIMULATOR WHERE THERE SOMEBODY
WITH YOUR YOUR WHERE IN THE USE
OF FORCE SITUATION. UNDER THE-
IF I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY THE CAL FIRE UNIT
WOULD BE LIVE FIRED THE TWO
MOBILE UNITS WOULD BE INFRARED.
SIMULATORS THAT'S ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. WELL I'M I'M TRYING
TO. FORCE OR IF THIS IS
PROVIDING FIRE LIKE IN A
STRUCTURE. THIS THESE ARE USE
OF FORCE AND- SO ARE THE LIVE
FIRE SIMULATOR CURRENTLY
SCHEDULE- PROPOSED TO GO TO CAL
FIRES ACADEMY. IS A LIVE FIRE
SIMULATOR SO OUR OFFICERS WOULD
ENTER THE FRONT OF THE
SIMULATOR SIMILARLY TO WHERE
I'M DRESSED WITH THEIR ACTUAL
DO TOGETHER ON AND BE ABLE TO
PLAY THEIR FORCE OPTIONS AS
APPROPRIATE BASED ON THE
SCENARIOS OF BASS BASS. WITHIN
THEIR- ENDED WITH IN THE
SCENARIOS ARE INDIVIDUAL
CONTACTS OF THE THOUSANDS OF
POTENTIAL OUTCOMES WHICH PUT
THOSE OFFICERS DIRECTLY IN THE
FACE OF THE NECESSITY OR OR
LACK THEREOF TO. BE UTILIZED
FOR. ELECTRONIC SIMULATORS WORK
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT WHEN
YOU'RE- TALKING ABOUT THE LIVE
FIRE TRAINING SIMULATOR AND ITS
LOCATION OF OFFER ATOMI.
COMPLIMENTS ARE EXISTING TRAIN
PLATFORMS THAT ARE BETTER SO WE
CAN. RUN NUMEROUS STUDENTS
THROUGH A FAST PACE TAKE THEM
OUT BUT IN A MINUTE PUTTING
THEM IN A THREE DIMENSIONAL
SCENARIO BASED TRAIN BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE FACILITIES ARE TO DO
IT. ANY ADDITIONAL RAIN SPACE.
WE CAN SAFELY OPERATE MULTIPLE
SCENARIOS AND RUN NUMEROUS
STUDENTS THROUGH. AT ONE POINT-
JUST MAKE SURE I'M TRACKING
BECAUSE I WANNA MAKE SURE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME TYPE OF
THE SIMULATOR. BUT I'M ASSUMING
YOU ALREADY HAVE SIMULATORS
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO FIGHT FIRE
DO STRUCTURE FIRE LIKE I SAW
OUT HERE. YOU DO NOT HAVE ONE
THAT IS A SIMULATOR THAT. THEY
PUT YOU IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU MAY HAVE TO USE FORCE.
THAT'S WAT THIS IS ABOUT. NOW
MY THIRD QUESTION WOULD BE.
DOES THE CHP OR- I'M ASSUMING
THERE'S OTHER AGENCIES THAT
HAVE THESE ALREADY OR THEY DO.
SO THERE'S NO ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO CROSS OVER AND- USE
THOSE OR IS IT ARE THESE MEANT
IN IN MY MIND THAT. THE
TAXPAYERS PAY IN. TWO FOUR C.
H. P. FISHING GAME WARDEN YOU
NAME IT YOU CAL FIRE. SO IT IS
OUR LACK OF THESE OF AVAILABLE
TO THOSE OTHER AGENCIES THAT WE
COULD USE WITH EACH OTHER OR IS
THIS THE FIRST ONES OUT OF THE
GATE. THAT ARE AVAILABLE. THERE
ARE OTHER TRAIN SIMULATORS
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BY INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES OR
REGIONAL TRAINING CENTERS. THE
NUMBER OF THOSE QUALITY OF
THOSE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THOSE. AS WE PROGRESS FORWARD
OUR BEHIND SO THAT'S WHY WE IS
A AGENCIES- AS A GROUP OF
AGENCIES ARE ASKING FOR TRAIN
SIMULATOR SPUR THE USE MONTHS
ARE AGENCIES. AS WELL AS WHAT.
IF I MAY SENATOR THERE'S A
COUPLE POINTS THERE TO THAT THE
MOST CURRENT TECHNOLOGY NOT
SIMULATOR TRAINING THAT WAS
POTENTIALLY PRIOR TO THIS
LEGISLATION. IN ADDITION TO
THAT I THINK THERE'S JUST A
COLLISION OF SO MANY PEOPLE
NEEDING TO GET TO THE EQUIPMENT
AND ALTHOUGH THERE IS A QUICK
MEN OUT THERE. IT'S NOT BILL
RIGHT NOW TO HANDLE THE
CAPACITY OF WORLD PEACE
OFFICERS IN THE STATE. MEMBER
BOARD DE ESCALATING. DE
ESCALATING CENTER STERN I'M
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WAS
WONDERING. AMAZING ON WE'VE
GONE THROUGH WITH PARKS IN.
ISSUE WILDLIFE AND SOME FOLKS
IN OUR MOUNTAINS WE HAD. THREE
MURDERS IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS NOT TOO LONG AGO SO
I'M ACTUALLY WAY TOO FAMILIAR
WITH THE- LEVEL OF RISK OUT
THERE THAT FACES YOUR RANK AND
FILE- SWORN PEACE OFFICERS I
WAS JUST HOPING YOU COULD LEND
A LITTLE INSIGHT. INTO IF YOU
HAVE SOME TOTAL NUMBERS ON USE
OF FORCE INCIDENTS INVOLVING
SWORN OFFICERS OR EVEN JUST
SOME SNAPSHOTS OF THE SORT OF
CONFLICT THAT MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
GOING ON OUT THERE IN THE FIELD
BECAUSE I EIGHT. THE REASON I
ASK IS I THINK IT'S- ONLY A
CAREFUL HERE HOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WERE SWORN IN TO DO THIS WORK
THAT. THERE'S A HIGH LEVEL OF
RISK IN THE JOB AND THERE'S A
SERIES LEVEL JUDGMENT IT'S
REQUIRED TO BE EXERCISED IN.
THIS IS NOT LIKE A SECOND CLASS
KIND OF LAWN FORCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE- I TAKE A
LOT OF PRIDE IN THAT. CASE THE
WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE TO
DEFEND. THE RIGHT TO FILE SWORN
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO. BIG BURDEN
TO BUT I JUST CAN YOU GIVE US A
SENSE HOW MANY INCIDENTS YEAR
HAVE YOU DONE THAT KIND OF
ANALYSIS OR EVEN JUST A-
SNAPSHOT BEYOND MY EXAMPLE OF.
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS WHICH
WAS A VERY SPECIFIC. ACTUALLY
IT. YEAH SERIAL KILLER
SEPARATISTS AS A VERY UNIQUE
SITUATION BUT ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS ONE OF THOSE CONFLICTS
LIKE. WELL ON BEHALF OF FISH
WILDLIFE. OCTOBER LAST DECADE
WE HAVE HAD EIGHT OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. SPECIFIC TO
OUR AGENCY ARM. THERE'S MOLD
AND THOSE ARE JUST THE ONES
WHERE WE HAD ACTUALLY A AN
OFFICER HAD TO FIRE THE WEAPON
IN DEFENSE OF THEMSELVES OR
SOMEONE ELSE. THERE'S MULTIPLE
TIMES RIDLEY CANDID THROUGHOUT
THE CALL THE COURSE OF THE YEAR
THAT ARE WARDENS WHO WORK OUT
IN REMOTE PLACES BY THEMSELVES
SINGULAR BY THEMSELVES WITH NO
BACK UP. WILLING COUNTER USE OF
FORCE SCENARIOS THE PRESENT
THEMSELVES TO THEM AND WE HAVE
A RANGE OF COURSE AND TRAINING
OF HOW TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
SCENARIOS AND DE ESCALATE OF
COURSE ALL THE WAY UP TO YOU
KNOW IN THE END USING YOUR
FIREARM AS A LAST RESORT BUT
THERE NUMEROUS FOR WILDLIFE
OFFICERS AND I SAID THAT NUMBER
YOU KNOW JUST AN OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. FIRST FOR
STATE PARKS CENTER WE'VE- WE
HAD- IN THE LAST JUST A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR TO OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS WE HAD AN INCIDENT ON
PORTIONS AND BIG SERVER AND-
ALSO DOWN IN THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AREA- WE DO SOME USE OF
FORCE TRACKING INTERNALLY AND
WE HAVE YOU KNOW JUST MAYBE
MORE ANECDOTAL THAN ANYTHING
BUT- A LITTLE OVER. FIFTY
INCIDENTS JUST AS AN EXAMPLE IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WERE-
WEAPON HAD TO BE DRAWN TO IN
EFFECT. AFFECT AN ARREST- WE
TRACK COUNT HOW MANY TIMES
WERE. HAVING TO USE A CHEMICAL
AGENT THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
WERE. YOU KNOW DOZENS OF
INCIDENTS A YEAR WE HAVE SOME
TRACKING ON THAT BUT I MEAN AS
YOU'RE WELL AWARE IN A ONE OR
TWO INCIDENTS WERE. SOMETHING
IS APPLIED. AND CONSISTENT WITH
THE LAW. AND AT ANY MOMENT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE AN ISSUE
THERE WITH. PUBLIC TRUST IN. ON
ON. SO WHAT CAN LAST KATE
CALPERS BEEN INVOLVED WITH TO
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS WERE
OUR OFFICERS WERE ACTUALLY.
ENGAGED IN AND- OUT FOR. THE
SUSPECT FORTUNATELY THE FIRST
INCIDENT THE. RESULT IN THE
FATALITY OF TWO. OTHER PEACE
OFFICERS ONE A CITY POLICE
OFFICER IN ONE NINE POLICE
OFFICER. AND THEN THE SECOND
WAS JUST RECENTLY MONTH OR TWO
AGO. SO THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
CERTAINLY. WHAT WHAT IN
RIVERSIDE THAT WAS THE
RIVERSIDE INCIDENT IT ALSO
INVOLVES STATE PARKS AS A
SEPARATE INCIDENTS THAT BURDENS
SEPARATE INCIDENT. HE WAS JUST
A SENSE OF THE NATURE OF THOSE
INCIDENTS I DON'T ASK FOR TOO
MUCH DETAIL BUT- THANK YOU WHAT
WHAT ACTUALLY. OCCURRED AT
LEAST AT A HIGH LEVEL THERE AND
STATE PARKS THE FIRST INCIDENT
TO THE RESULT IN THE FATALITY
OF TWO OFFICERS WAS A WANT
SERVICE ON AN ARSON SUSPECT.
WORN SERVICE ON AN ARSON
SUSPECT BARRICADED HIMSELF UP
IN A STRUCTURE AND SO QUE. I
MEAN FAR TOWARDS OFFICER. THE
LATEST OUR OFFICER ROLLED BACK
UP. THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY SO.
WHO PUT A CALL OUT FOR
ASSISTANCE AND. LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC CARRY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO COMMENT THIS IS.
ISSUE NUMBER. FIFTEEN AND USE
OF DEADLY FORCE TRAINING YES
MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER LACK AND
DE ESCALATE USE OF DEADLY FORCE
I JUST WANTED TO OFFER SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING GAME WARDENS
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. TAX.
MISTER CHAIR PATRON WITH THEIR
IN READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENT
CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO EIGHT ONE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
CLOSE THE ES. PUBLIC HEARING
BRING IT BACK THERE'S A MOTION
BY CENTER DOLLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ASKING HI. ONLY MCGUIRE
MINING I. I CLOSE ROTEL YOU
VOTE I SEVEN FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU WILL CHANGE THE CHAIRS
LET'S GO BACK TO OUR VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WHERE MEMBERS ARE
COMING UP LET'S CALL THE- LET'S
RECALL MOTION NUMBER ONE.
ISSUES. ONE TWO THREE FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE. PLEASE CALL
THE MISS ABSENT MEMBERS ALI.
MONNING THANK CLOSE ROLE TALLY
VOTES I SEVEN FIVE ZERO LET'S
HOPE LET'S OPEN THE ROLL CALL
ON MOTION NUMBER TWO THIS IS
ISSUES NUMBER FOUR AND AT TEN
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALI. MONNING HI. CLOSE ROLE
TALLY VOTES THE EYES HAVE
AFFORD ONE. AND WE HAVE. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN UP PLEASE CALL
THE MISSING ARE ABSENT MEMBERS
MONNING HI. CLOSE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE THE AYES HAVE A FOUR
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE THIS IS FISHING
FOR ONE IS ME FOR ONE. HI THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
TECHNICAL BUDGETING. I JUST.
THREE AND YOU SEE PEACE. I
WOULD LIKE TO START OFF THEIR
FOR AGENCIES. MR TERM HAPPY TO.
MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- CHRISTOPHER TRAIL
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR INTEGRATED
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES JOINED HERE BY
DIRECTOR BOND OF COURSE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD FROM PREVIOUS.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WE'RE HERE TO REQUEST
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR OUR FOUR DIFFERENT AGENCIES
AND I'LL JUST START OUT WITH
BOTH A CLICHE AND A TRUISM AND
THAT IS THAT YOU CANNOT MANAGE
WHAT YOU CANNOT MEASURE AND
THAT WAS THE WISDOM THAT WAS
DRIVING SB NINETEEN BY SENATOR
DODD I SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR IN THE REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
STATE'S STREAM GAUGING NETWORK.
BUT THEN IF I IN PRIORITIZE
GAUGING DATA GAPS AND DEVELOP
AN INTEGRATED PLAN TO IMPROVE
STREAM GAUGE DATA AVAILABILITY
THE STREAM GAGES OR IS
ESSENTIALLY JUST SIMPLE
TECHNOLOGY PLACE RIGHT NEXT TO
OUR STREAM AND RIVER COURSES
THAT ALLOW FOR- THE MANAGEMENT.
OF WATER RESOURCES NESS FOR
SINGLE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT.
FLOOD EMERGENCY RESPONSE WATER
SUPPLY OPERATIONS WATER QUALITY
WATER RIGHTS ADMINISTRATION
ECOSYSTEM MONITORING YOU NAME
IT. I WAS REALLY FUNDAMENTAL-
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
NECESSARY FOR. OVER ARCHING
WATER MANAGEMENT. AND THIS IS
JUST AGAIN FUNDING SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF LEGISLATION.
PASSED LAST YEAR AND THAT
REQUIRES A CONFERENCE OF STUDY
OF WHAT WE HAVE WHAT WE NEED.
RESET YOUR SUPPORT. THE ONE WE
HAVE ANYTHING THAT ONE THING
THANK. IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET A
PRECISE ESTIMATE BUT OUR
JUDGMENT IS ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF OUR TOTAL
WATERSHEDS IN THE STATE. DON'T
REALLY HAVE A SYSTEM OF EITHER
STATE OR FEDERALLY SPONSORED
GAUGING UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH THE MOVEMENT OF WATER.
HOW DO YOU GAUGE THE SAYS.
ALEJO GIVE. THIS PROPOSAL I'M
SO I'LL I'LL MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT OF ALL THREE OF THE B. C.
P.'S YOU HAVE IN THIS ITEM
BECAUSE OUR OUR COMMENTS ARE
THE SAME FOR A B. AND C. READ A
MEMBERS WILL BE TAKING EACH OF
THE THREE SEPARATELY AS IT AS
SET. FORTH IN THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AB AND C. WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
ANY OF THESE REQUESTS IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS- FOR
WORKLOAD. I THINK OUR OVER
ARCHING CONCERNED ABOUT ALL
THREE OF THESE PROPOSES IS ALL
OF THEM ARE. PROPOSING TO FUN
IN EXISTING POSITIONS THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW IN OUR FUNDED
RIGHT NOW. BUT THEY ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. COMPARED TO
SUBSEQUENT YEARS. SAID AND WE
DIDN'T SEE A RATIONALE FOR THAT
SO AS YOU AS YOU LIKELY ARE
FAMILIAR NORMALLY WHEN A
DEPARTMENT COMES FORTH TO
ESTABLISH NEW POSITIONS. THEY
OFTEN ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN THE FIRST YEAR TO
SET THAT POSITION UP THEY MAY
NEED A COMPUTER THEY MAY NEED A
CUBICLE BUTTE BUILD OUT THEY
MAY NEED- SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING JUST TO GET UP AND
GOING IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
THEN IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS THE-
AMOUNT IS SLIGHTLY LESS. BUT
GIVEN THAT THE THIRTY POSITIONS
ACROSS ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS
ARE ALL EXISTING POSITIONS THAT
ALREADY HAVE THEIR COMPUTERS
AND CUBICLES AND WE'RE JUST.
SWITCHING FUNDING SOURCE ARE
MAKING FUNDING ON GOING WE
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE
FOR- PROVIDE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE FIRST
YEAR IT'S A TOTAL OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ACROSS ALL OF THE
THIRTY. DECISIONS DEMONSTRATION
HAS SUGGESTED THERE- REDOING
THEIR INTERNAL ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
FOR CHARGING INDIRECT BUT- THAT
WASN'T A RATIONALE FOR US FOR
WHY THE STATE OUGHT TO BE
SPENDING MORE MONEY IN ONE YEAR
COMPARED TO OTHERS. THAT WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THESE
PROPOSALS BUT APPROVING THEM AT
THE LEVELS REQUESTED FOR THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS. WITH
ADDITIONAL FIVE IN FIFTY IN THE
FIRST YEAR. AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SAYS. THE THIRD
DRIVER PART OF FINANCE SO L.
THE ALLEY NOTED SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH PART OF
WATER RESOURCES ON JUST GONNA
EVALUATING THEIR OVERHEAD AT
THE METHODOLOGY AND SO- THIS IS
GONNA MERELY A FACTORS AS MORE
TECHNICAL THAN ANYTHING REALLY
I JUST KNOW THAT. BUDGET YOUR
MAIL IS ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY LOWER
THAN WHAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE
AUTHORIZED BECAUSE OF OUR
EVALUATION OF THAT OVERHEAD
METHODOLOGY- BUT YEAH IT'S A
MUTE MERELY TECHNICAL. HEY
LET'S. OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN ONE TECHNICAL BUDGETING
ADJUSTMENTS ANYBODY IN THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN.
CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING. I'M SORRY
SAID. OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING
GO AHEAD YEARS CHECK A THIRD ON
THE BEHALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY CAL TROUT AND TRY
TO LIMITED IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR STREAM GAUGING IN
PARTICULAR AS INITIATIVE AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR QUITE
SOME TIME NOW GLAD TO SEE IT
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. THANK
YOU. IS THIS THE IN SITU OR
JUST. HEY. CENTRAL VALLEY A
FLOOD CONTROL BOARD ANYWAY XIN
OF EXISTING STAFFING BUT WHEN
THIS ROBERT COR FROM THE GLOBAL
GROUP FOR B. AND C. ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AUTHORITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BOTH THOSE TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL THE AGENCIES
FOR DECADES. THANK YOU. NOW
WE'LL CLOSE.
ALL.
THIS IS. FIVE
WHY ARE.
WHEREAS. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATORS ARE ASKED AND ANSWERED
A COUPLE DIFFERENT WAYS ONE IS
JUST BE REALLY CLEAR WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS ANSWERING
THE VERY QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING IN A WAY RIGHT THIS IS
TO DO THE COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
THAT THAT IS REQUIRED OF US BY
SB NINETEEN AND SO THEN GETTING
TO HOW I BELIEVE IT WILL BE
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION WHICH I
THINK S ACTUALLY GETS TO YOUR
YOUR QUESTION IN TURN IS REALLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES
OF LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
COORDINATION AS GOOD AS THOSE
RELATED TO THE STREAM GAUGING
SYSTEM. SO WHAT WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE EXPECTING IN THIS
AND THIS- RESULTING SB NINETEEN
REPORT. IS WHAT IS THE STATUS
OF THE USGS STATIONS THEY
TRADITIONALLY HAVE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED OR SIX HUNDRED ACROSS
THE STATE. WHERE THOSE IN
RELATION TO THOSE MANAGED BY.
FORMER WATER RESOURCES WHERE
THOSE RELATION TO THOSE MANAGED
BY. DOCTOR BONHAM SHOP AND
LOCAL AGENCIES AND LIKE YOU
SUGGEST GROUPS LIKE. THE GENIE
THAT HAVE THEIR OWN FACILITIES
OUT THERE. IT ONLY MAKES SENSE
TO INVEST IN NEW FACILITIES
WHERE THERE ARE THOSE DATA
GAPS. IT MAKES SENSE TO DO THIS
ANALYSIS FIRST AS OF THE
SMARTEST INVESTMENTS POSSIBLE.
BETTER THIS IS NOT A PROPOSAL.
ON THE ACTUAL GAUGES IT'S A
PROPOSAL TO DO THE ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT. THE NETWORK SHOULD BE.
AND THEN COME BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION. YES ABSOLUTELY.
THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE STREAM GAUGING
PLAN IMPLEMENTATION THIS IS THE
ONE POINT FIVE FOUR ONE MILLION
OF WHICH HUNDRED MILLION COMES
IN THE WATER RIGHTS FIND OVER
TWO YEARS AND ONE POINT ONE
FOUR ONE. MILLION COMES GENERAL
FUND. MOTION BY CENTER MINING
PLEASE CULTURAL. CASKEY HI ONLY
REQUIRE. MORNING I. OKAY MATTER
OPEN MOTION NUMBER TWO WILL BE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD
PROTECTION POURED CONTINUATION
EXISTING STAFFING THIS IS
THREE. POINT SIX EIGHT EIGHT
MILLION IN GENERAL FUNDS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
POINT SIX EIGHT EIGHT MILLION
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. BY CENTER
MINING IS CULTURAL ASKING HI
ONLY. WHERE RUNNING I CAN KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN AND FINALLY A
MOTION ON FLOOD OF PLANNING
RESOURCING THIS IS APPROVED TWO
POINT ZERO EIGHT NINE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND ONE TIME IN TWO
ON GOING THERE AFTER. I CENTER
MONNING PLEASE CALDERON ASKING
I ONLY. REQUIRE MONEY I WILL
KEEP THAT MATTER OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE TO IT
ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN HI DREW
METEOROLOGY AND SURFACE WATER
OBSERVATIONS. GOOD AFTERNOON
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
IN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS MY NAME IS CARLA
NEMETH AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES I'M VERY PLEASED TO
BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON TO
DISCUSS OUR BUDGET ITEMS- WITH
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE I WANT TO
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THIS IS A VERY EXCITING TIME TO
BE INVOLVED IN CALIFORNIA'S
WATER RESOURCE MANAGEMENT AND
IT'S THE DEPARTMENT'S VIEW THAT
WE WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL
WITHOUT STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE MANY MANY LOCAL WATER%
AGENCIES. FLOOD CONTROL
DISTRICT'S NEWLY FORMED
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY
BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
AND THE MANY OTHER CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE ENGAGED WITH US AND HOW
BEST TO SECURE CALIFORNIA'S
WATER FUTURE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES ECONOMY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
AN INCREDIBLE IMPERATIVE FOR
THE STATE- WE CERTAINLY FEEL IT
IN THE AREA OF WATER RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT- AND WITH THAT WE
HAVE MORE DETAILS ON- SEVERAL
PROPOSALS THAT WE THINK
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE RESILIENT
WATER SUPPLIES FOR CALIFORNIANS
ON THIS FIRST- BUDGET TOPIC-
THE PROPOSAL REQUESTS SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. FOR ELEVEN
POSITIONS TO SUPPLY HYDRO
METEOROLOGY AND SURFACE WATER
OBSERVATIONS PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT. DO YOU HAVE
YOUR IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAINTAINING TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY REMOTE WEATHER STATIONS
THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION FOR FLOOD EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND WATER SUPPLY
FORECASTING. THE SIX MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS PROVIDE
STAFFING RESOURCES AND
EQUIPMENT TO ENHANCE SURFACE
WATER MONITORING BY
REACTIVATING AN UPGRADING
EXISTING MONITORING STATIONS OR
INSTALLING NEW STATIONS TO
ADDRESS KNOWN INFORMATION GAPS.
THE OBSERVATIONS MADE BY THESE
MONITORING SITES ARE
INCREASINGLY CRUCIAL TO SMART
WATER MANAGEMENT GIVEN THE
CLIMATE IMPACTS ON OUR
HYDROLOGY AND OUR NEW
IMPERATIVE TO BRING GROUND
WATER BASINS INTO BALANCE. AS
AN EXAMPLE THE USE OF STATIONS
ARE IMPORTANT SOURCES OF
INFORMATION FOR FARMERS IN
CALIFORNIA IT HELPS THEM TO
DETERMINE THEIR IRRIGATION
NEEDS MANAGE THEIR SURFACE
WATER DIVERSIONS AND THEIR
GROUND WATER EXTRACTIONS. AND
WITH THAT- I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. THESE AGAIN CHRISTIAN
OFTEN FORMER WHAT RESOURCES
JUST BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL THIS ISN'T REALLY A
COMPLIMENT TO THE LAST ONE YOU
HEARD RELATED TO SB NINE
IMPLEMENTATION SB NINETEEN
IMPLICATION THAT WAS RELATED
TO. WHAT IT IS SURFACE WATER
STREAM GAUGE REQUIREMENTS ARE
NEEDS RATHER ACROSS THE STATE
THIS IS REALLY LOOKING AT THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY- WEATHER
STATIONS- CALLS THE MISTAKE
SHINS OR CALIFORNIA YOUR
ADDITION MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM STATIONS THAT COMPLEMENT
THOSE. SERVICE WATER GAUGES-
THESE ARE LARGELY PLACED IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS ACROSS THE
STATE AND AS A DIRECTOR
MENTIONED REALLY HELP FIND THAT
GREAT THAT BALANCE THE
AGRICULTURAL AND INDUSTRY IN
PARTICULAR NEEDS BETWEEN. A
WHEN IS THE BEST TO FOR SERVICE
WATER VERSES GROUNDWATER WHAT
IS THE WEATHER LOOKING LIKE IN
THIS MOMENT WHAT'S COMING OUR
WAY. WHERE IS THE SNOW PACK
WHERE'S THE PRECIPITATION THIS
REALLY IS A COMPLIMENT IF YOU
WELL TO THAT- PREVIOUS ITEM YOU
VOTED ON. HOW DOES ONE MAINTAIN
OR OUR SERVICE A GAUGE WHAT'S
WHAT IT I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THAT IS. YEAH SO THE- IT WAS A
THAT IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS ONE
IS SIMPLY GETTING THERE. SO
JUST LIKE THE STREAM GAGES AT
THE SAME A STATION'S WEATHER
STATIONS ARE LOCATED GENERALLY
IN PRETTY REMOTE AREAS SOME ARE
LESS REMOTE IF THEY'RE ACTUALLY
ON I I'M YOUR GATED
AGRICULTURAL. AREAS BUT SOME
ARE. VERY MUCH- FAR FLUNG. I'M
ACROSS THE ACROSS THE STATE WE
REALLY DO NEED IS INFORMATION
STATEWIDE AND SO JUST GETTING
THERE SO TRANSPORTATION- THAT
REQUIRES VEHICLES OF COURSE-
BUT BY THINK PREDOMINATELY TO
YOUR QUESTION IT REALLY IS THE-
THESE ARE. HIGHLY ADVANCED-
MONITORING STATIONS SO IT'S
WIND SPEED TEMPERATURE OF WATER
QUALITY PRECIPITATION SNOW MELT.
I'M JUST TO BE ABLE TO MEASURE
SNOW FALL YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A VERY SENSITIVE
MACHINE THAT NOT ONLY AS A AS A
PAD IF YOU WILL TO CATCH SO.
AND SNOWFALL BUT ALSO HAS TO BE
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO- HAVE THAT
MELTING AWAY THAT THAN THAT
AMOUNT OF SNOW BASED OFF OF
BOTH THE WATER CONTENT ANN'S
WEIGHT IS MEASURED CALCULATED
SO A LOT OF VERY SENSITIVE
TECHNOLOGIES WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET ACROSS HERE. THAT JUST LIKE
OUR AUTOMOBILES REQUIRES
CONSTANT VIGILANCE- UPDATING
UPGRADING AND MAINTENANCE TO
MAKE SURE THEY WERE GETTING THE
MOST ACCURATE INFORMATION
POSSIBLE IF IT'S NOT ACCURATE
IT'S NOT REALLY USEFUL WHY I
GET THAT WHEN YOU GO OUT AND
YOU HAVE A- PORTABLE. HI AM
GADGET IN YOU AND YOU DO THE
MEASUREMENT WERE THAT LEASE
THIS PCP BCP TALKS ABOUT TWENTY
STREAM CAGES THAT ARE OUT THERE
ALREADY YOU WANT TO YOU WANT
STAFF AND YOU WANT SOME MONEY
TO GO MAINTAIN THEM IS IT A
MATTER JUST SIMPLE CALIBRATION
TO MAKE SURE ITS OPERATING
RIHT OR- IS IT. ARE THESE. IN
THE WORLD OF STREAM GAUGES
SISTER SOME NEW ELEMENT THAT
GOES IN THAT YOU REPLACE LIKE
A- YOU KNOW. AN AUTOMOBILE YOU
TAKE THIS PART OUT YOU PUT THIS
PART IN IN THAT IT PROVIDES
DATA. AND YOU KNOW I ASSUME WE
WANNA UP OUR GAME BY BY DOING
THE SO IT'S BOTH I'M A RECENT
EXAMPLE WAS A IN THE SOUTHERN-
SO YOU'RE A WATERSHED- ARE
SOUTHERN REGIONAL OFFICE- IN
OUR FRESNO OFFICE. RECEIVE SOME
FEEDBACK FROM OF FOR EXAMPLE
THE FRONT WATER DISTRICT THAT
SOME OF THE DATA THAT THEY WERE
RELYING ON UP IN THE SIERRA
WATERSHED WAS NO LONGER COMING
THROUGH. SO THAT INVOLVED- THE
DEPARTMENT WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO GO OUT TO
THAT STATION AND THERE WAS SOME
AVALANCHE ACTIVITY THAT TOOK
OUT PART OF THE EQUIPMENT. AND
OF THE ROLE OF THE DEPARTMENT
WAS TO WORK WITH A LOCAL AGENCY
TO REHABILITATE THAT PARTICULAR
STATION AND MAKE SURE THAT IT
WAS PROVIDING DATA IN. A TIMELY
WAY AND THAT'S AN OBVIOUS
EXAMPLE WHERE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT I'M
PARTICULARLY IN PLACES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE WE'VE GOT
SOME CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
GROUND WATER BASINS THAT. NEED
TO COME INTO BALANCE OVER THE
NEXT TWO DECADES. THANK YOU.
BUT LET'S SUPPOSE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN ANY. COMMENTS MORNING
AGAIN- RATHER THAN ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY CAL
TROUT AND TROUT UNLIMITED- I
THINK DEPARTMENT STAFF AND
COMMITTEE STAFF SAID IT VERY
WELL SO WE ABSOLUTE
WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT THIS.
PROPOSAL AS WELL THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING IS OUR MOTION. CENTER
I'M AYE SIR DOLLY YEAH.
VERY
LITTLE IF ANY IS DUPLICATED SO
BECAUSE GENERALLY ARE RESOURCES
OF ALWAYS BEEN CONSTRAINED TO
SOME DEGREE APPROPRIATELY SO-
WE'VE ONLY BEEN ABLE TO AND
WHAT THEY REALLY EVER WANTED TO
PLACE THESE WHERE THE
INFORMATION IS NOT BEING
GATHERED LIKE I MENTIONED ON
THE STREAM GAUGE I'M PROPOSAL
EARLIER IN THE CONVERSATION AND
THERE IS A SIMILARLY STRONG
COORDINATED EFFORT BETWEEN
STATE FEDERAL LOCAL AGENCIES ON
WHERE THESE WEATHER STATIONS
ARE PLACED IN SO THERE'S LOTS
OF SHARING OF INFORMATION ALL
OF THE INFORMATION ACTUALLY
THAT WE GET FROM BOTH STREAM
GAUGES AND THESE WEATHER
STATIONS IS AVAILABLE PUBLICLY-
ESSENTIALLY IN REAL TIME AND
THAT'S REALLY THE BENEFIT SO IS
A LOT OF COORDINATION HERE AS
WELL. I TENDER MINING THIS CALL
THE ROLL CASKEY HI AILEEN.
REQUIRE MORNING TURN TO ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MOVING
THE ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN IT'S
NEW- NO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WE
WERE ASKED. SENATE DOLLY
REMOVED I ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
SO LET'S GO BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN WHICH IS THE
TREND TRANSMISSION OPERATOR
COMPLIANCE THIS IS TWENTY THREE
NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS. AT S.
W. P. SO ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE
OUR MISTER TED CRADDICK HE'S
THE ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE STATE WATER PROJECT- AND
HE'S HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THIS ITEM. OKAY MORNING
SENATORS GOOD MORNING THANK
THANKS FOR BEING HERE SEE YOU
GET NEWARK PLOPPED ON YOUR ON
YOUR DESK TENER DOLLY IF
QUESTIONS. YEAH I'D BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE CONTEXT
TO THAT SO THE NATION IN THE
STATE'S ELECTRIC GRID ARE YOU
KNOW EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- FOR
YOU KNOW IN OUR OVERALL COUNTRY
AND IN STATE IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT RELIABILITY. SO
IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS-
THERE WAS A MAJOR BLACKOUT ON
THE EAST COAST THAT. REALLY
STARTED THE INDUSTRY TO TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT AT PROTECTING
THE NATION IN STATES- ELECTRIC
GRID IN TERMS OF RELIABILITY
AND THEN MORE RECENTLY IN THE
LAST DECADE OR SO FROM CYBER
ATTACK- SO THERE ARE- AT THREE
MAIN ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED
WITH REGULATED IN THE NATION
AND IN STATE ELECTRIC GRID THAT
INCLUDES THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION THAT SETS
POLICY. AT THE NORTH AMERICAN
ELECTRIC RELIABILITY COUNCIL
THAT- ESTABLISHES BASICALLY
PROCEDURES AND REGULATIONS FOR
ELECTRIC UTILITIES- TO- FOLLOW
AND THEN THE WESTERN ENERGY TO
BREAK. AYE LECTER COORDINATING
COUNCIL THAT BASICALLY ENSURES
THAT UTILITIES ARE IMPLEMENTING
THOSE POLICIES TO PROTECT THE
ELECTRIC GRID ASSELIN LATE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE RECEIVED A
REQUIREMENT FROM THE WESTERN
ELECTRICITY- COORDINATING
COUNCIL. TO AT IS A TREE
OPERATOR FOR THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND SPECIFICALLY THAT'S
FOR THE- BANKS PUMPING PLANT
FACILITIES WHICH AB
TRANSMISSION LINES- CONNECTED
TO THE STATE'S GRID- THAT THAT
WE OWN AND THEN ADDITIONALLY-
FOUR DOES TO ME GOES PUMPING
PLAN. AS A RESULT OF THAT- WHAT
WERE REQUIRED TO DO IS TO
REGISTER IS A TRANSMISSION
OPERATOR TO ESTABLISH WHAT'S
CALLED A OPERATION DESKS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN OPERATIONS CENTER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THAT
OPERATES THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. AS A WILL BE ADDING A-
RAIDERS FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
THESE TO TRADE AND FACILITIES
FOR THESE FACILITIES AND THEN
UNDER THE- MILITARY
REQUIREMENTS WE'RE ALSO ALSO
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH WHAT'S
CALLED A BACK UP DANCER. IN THE
MAIN OPERATING SENT. BACK
OPERATING SO- THESE POSITIONS
ARE INTENDED TO. ADD THESE TWO
SENATORS. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO
COMPLIANCE WITH A- DIRECT.
AMEND WE CAN CAN OPERATE WATER
PROJECT. ALSO WE ARE ESTA OUR
INITIAL START UP COST WHICH
INCLUDES- YOU KNOW ADDING
SYSTEMS- SOFTWARE YOU KNOW JUST
TO ROUTE TO RUN THIS AND TO
INTERACT WITH A CAL I SO AND
THE IN OTHER UTILITIES TO BE
ABOUT THIRTEEN MILLION OF OUR
WE HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO BE
READY TO GO IN THE FALL OF THIS
YEAR SO WE'RE AT WORKING ON
THAT IN THE END THIS REQUEST IS
REALLY FOR THE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS TO NAP OFF THE STILL
IS- WE'RE EXPECTING THIS
POSITIONS WHERE ANNUAL COST OF
ABOUT FOUR MILLION. YEAH. I
ALSO HAS A ROLE IN THE OVERALL
MANAGEMENT OF THE STATE'S
ELECTRIC GRID ANDTHEN UNDER
THOUGH THE WAY IT'S SET UP- THE
UTILITIES ALSO HAVE OVER A ROLE
TO ENSURE THAT THAT WERE AT
PROTECTING OUR FACILITIES
MANAGING OUR FACILITIES
MAINTAINING THE FACILITIES MEN
ALSO INTERACT IN THAT ELECTRIC
MARKETS- I IN A WAY THAT THE
FACILITATES YOU KNOW OVERALL
OPERATION SO IT'S A REALLY
COMBINED APPROACH BETWEEN
CALAIS SO. DIFFERENT UTILITIES
IN THE STATE. HE. I AM. OR.
YEAH. YES SO I'D SAY THEM ONE
ONE PIECE INFORMATION IS THAT
CALLAWAY'S SO HAS A ROLE PLUS
THE UTILITIES HAVE A ROLE WITH
WHICH IS CONTINUING TO EVOLVE
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES IS
THE YOU KNOW THE REQUIREMENTS
TO PROTECT THE RED AND INSURE
THAT THAT THE GRID IS SAFE AND
NOT VULNERABLE TO CYBER ATTACK
IS WHAT REALLY RESPONDING TO
STOP RESPONDING TO A
REQUIREMENT FROM THE WEST.
ELECTRICITY RELY WE CAN'T PULL
THAT MANDY IN US TO TAKE ON
THIS ROLE FOR ADDITIONAL
REINFORCEMENT OF ELECTRIC GRID
RIGHT A POINT OF CLARIFICATION
A PRIOR TO THIS P. JEANNIE
SERVE THIS FUNCTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE DON'T LONG
STANDING CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM IN LATE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THEY DECLINED
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE FURTHER.
TO OUR APPROACH HAS BEEN TO NOW
BRING THIS IN HOUSE SO THAT WE
CAN MAINTAIN OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH AYE A SO- MOVING FORWARD.
FIRE ALL. WE WERE PAYING THIS
BILL TO P. JEANNIE AND NOW WE
ARE ESSENTIALLY BRINGING THAT
SERVICE AND HOUSE. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. AT ANY RATE
THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU. YET I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE- THE YOU KNOW THE I
THINK OUR IN A PERFECT WORLD
WE'D LIKE P. JEANNIE TO
CONTINUE IN THIS ROLE AND SO
THAT WAS ONE APPROACH WE LOOKED
AT- BUT REGARDLESS YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO CONTINUE OPERATING THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE THIS NEW
REQUIREMENT PLACED ON US SO
WE'RE- PROCEEDING PROACTIVELY
TO BE OVER THE KEEP THE STATE
WATER PROJECT FUNCTION IN.
FURTHER POINT OF CLARIFICATION
IS THIS IS PROPOSED TO BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE STATEWATER
PROJECT FUNDS OF THIS IS NOT A
GENERAL FUND REQUEST THIS IS
FUNDED BY TE WATER USERS WHO
RECEIVE THE BENEFIT OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT. ABSOLUTELY
RATE PAYERS PAY FOR THIS THAT
VERY VERY TRUE. WE HAVE
ANYTHING THAT NO JUST WE ASKED
A LOT OF THESE SAME QUESTIONS
WHEN WE WERE LOOKING INTO THIS
AND THE HEARD A SIMILAR STORY
WHICH IS JUST THAT THIS CAT.
FROM FEDERAL REGULATORS COMING
IN AND LOOKING MORE CLOSELY
AND- REQUIRING THE SERVICE AND
P. JEANNIE DECLINED TO DO IT.
TO REALLY PUTTING THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE POSITION OF
NEEDING TO DO IT I THINK I
RECALL THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE
THE DEADLINE WE START GETTING A
FEE OF. MILLION DOLLARS A DAY
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT FROM
BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE SO THE
STAKES ARE ARE PRETTY HIGH SO
IN OUR- INSTIGATION IT SEEMED
LIKE THIS WAS THE OPTION LEFT.
TO THE STATE. GOOD THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
LET'S OPEN UP TO PUBLIC
HEARING. IT'S THIS TRANSMISSION
OPERATOR. TO BE. THE STATE
WATER. HI NOBODY ON PUBLIC
HEARINGS CLOSE SET. MEMBERS
AFRICAN NATIONS TO PROVE HIS
BUDGET. THERE'S A MOTION BY
CENTER MINING PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL I CASTING HI ONLY. REQUIRE
MORNING. LEAVE THAT MATTER OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
LET'S JUMP BACK. THE NEW RIVER
IN TIJUANA RIVER. OR FORWARD
JUMP FORWARD. SPRING FORWARD
SEEMS TO BE WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING. THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. OKAY THIS OF THIS
ITEM IS ACTUALLY EMBLEMATIC OF
THE KINDS OF PARTNERSHIPS AMONG
STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT AS REQUIRED- AND
WILL BE REQUIRED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR WATER SECURITY AND
QUALITY CONCERNS IN CALIFORNIA-
WITH ME TODAY IS ERIC JARVIS-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
UP BEFORE YOU. IS A- REQUEST
FOR- TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS A TEN MILLION OF WHICH-
WOULD BE PROPOSED TO COME FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. EIGHTEEN
MILLION FROM PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT TO DIVERT TREAT AND RE
WATER THE NATURAL RIVER COURSE.
THE CITY OF CALEXICO HAS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDE ONGOING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE FOR
THIS FACILITY UPKEEP. THE
SECOND PROJECT IS THE TIJUANA
RIVER PROJECT- IT'S SIMILAR- IN
ITS GOAL IS TO CAPTURE
POLLUTION. THROUGH A SERIES OF
SEDIMENTATION AND DETENTION
BASINS TO REDUCE THE VOLUME OF
CONTAMINATED WATER TRASH AND
SENTIMENT INTO THE TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY ESTUARY. THE
BUDGET REQUESTS THERE IS THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND FOR THE SERIES OF
PROJECTS. WE KNOW THAT THE LA
HAS IS CONCERNED OVER THE
ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS FACILITIES- I
WOULD INVITE- MY COLLEAGUE.
MISTER JARVIS TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE BACKGROUND ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH WATER
CONTAMINATION IN THIS PART OF
THE STATE. BEFORE YOU START
JUST SO EVERYBODY OUR STAFF
REPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IS EIGHTEEN MILLION FROM
GENERAL FUND TEN MILLION FROM-
PROP- SIXTY INADVERTENTLY FLIP
DOES NOW I. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE'S. SHAKING IN THEIR
IN THEIR LIKE CHAIRS OVER THERE
I HEARD THE SAME THING ALRIGHT
MR VERSUS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
NAME S. FOR THE RECORD JARVIS
COUNTY PA GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS. IF YOU MEAN DIRECTOR
NAME THIS BRIEF BRIEF OVERVIEW
APTLY DESCRIBE OUR TO PROPOSAL
SO IN THE INTEREST OF TIME. IT
IS SOME KEY HIGHLIGHTS
PARTICULARLY COLLABORATION. AS
YOU KNOW THE NEW RIVER INTO ONE
RIVER AS WELL AS THE CANYON'S
ADJACENT ARE POLLUTED WATER
BODIES SO THIS ALL BEGAN AS
WATER QUALITY ISSUES. AND AS
YOU LIKELY ALSO NOW WATER
QUALITY ISSUES UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF THE STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS AND SO
CALLIE PEES BORDER AFFAIRS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER BOARDS TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE. WATER
QUALITY CHALLENGES OF TRANS
BOUNDARY FLOWS. BECAUSE THE
SOLUTIONS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR INVOLVE WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE CONSTRUCTION
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IS THE APPROPRIATE FIT TO
MANAGE THIS PROGRAM AND HAS
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA. SO
COLLECTIVELY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE RESOURCES
AGENCY NDW ARE. WE COLLABORATED
TO VOTE TO DEVELOP A SKI SUITE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
AT THE RIVERS. WHEN THE
GOVERNOR UNVEILED THE JAN TEN
BUDGET HE HIGHLIGHTED MANY
AREAS THAT NEED OUR ATTENTION.
SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZING THE
SCALE AND IMMEDIACY. OF OUR
CLIMATE PROBLEM AND THE NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY. INCREASE AND
LEVERAGE INVESTMENTS ON VARIOUS
WATER. ISSUES NOTABLY THE NEW
ANTI ONE RIVERS. BUT WE NEED TO
BE MORE COMMITTED TO THIS
EFFORT AND SO THE GOVERNOR
COMMITTED TO TACKLING LONG
STANDING TELLING LONG ARE SURE
BORDER WITH MEXICO. HE ALSO
COMMITTED TO FOSTERING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES BUILT BY NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS MEXICO. IN
BAJA CALIFORNIA AND BAJA OR- AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE GOVERNOR
SIGNING THE COMMISSION
CALIFORNIA'S MEMORY. OF A
STANDING. SOMEWHERE YOU FURTHER
ENABLES US TO PARTNER WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES THE FEDERAL STATE
AND WE NEED. TO MAKE THE CALL.
TO STREAMLINE OUR BILL TO
ADDRESS SHIP ANDREAS AND TO A-
OPPORTUNITY. NUMBER EIGHT. WE
CHALLENGES NEW ONE RIVERS IN
ADDITION TO ERROR CALL MOBILITY
TRANSPORTATION AND OVER ON
FORCE CHALLENGES ARE HIGH
PRIORITIES FOR THIS- FOR THIS
COLLABORATION AND AT THE VERY
HEART OF THE PRINCIPLES WITHIN
MA'AM ARE YOU. WELL WE'VE
HISTORICALLY LOOK TO FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO ASSIST WITH PUBLIC
RICK REDUCTION LONG THE BORDER%
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY THE GOVERNOR
HAS CHAMPION OUR SUPPORT FOR
REGIONAL AND LOCAL CAPACITY TO
ACHIEVE IMPROVEMENTS AND WATER
QUALITY AND TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. ARE
VIABLE COASTLINE PARKS AND
NATURAL RESOURCES AMONG GOING
WASTE DISCHARGES. AT THE RISK
OF PREEMPTING NEARLY ALL I
WANTED TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
ON GOING ON ONE AND FOR TWO ONE
RIVER. AS DESCRIBED IN THE
AGENDA BOTH SETS OF PROJECTS
WILL BE FUNDED THROUGH LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND WE'VE
INCLUDED TWO YEARS AGO AND AM
IN OUR PROPOSAL FOR WASTE
CAPTURE THE TIJUANA RIVER. THE
CONCERN THE CONSULTANT ONLY
OPPOSE REGARDING SECURING
ONGOING OWN AND FINDING IS
VALID. KELLY PA HAS BEEN
SPEARHEADING DISCUSSIONS WITH
FEDERAL LOCAL AND STATE
ENTITIES FOR THESE PROJECTS.
THESE PAST FEW MONTHS CAL HE BE
A SPOKEN WITH COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO THE CITY OF THEM PEARL
BEACH MEXICO COUNTERPARTS THE
INTERNATIONAL BOUNDARY AND
WATER OF WATER COMMISSIONS WELL
AS US EPA AND OTHER FEDERAL
ENTITIES. THROUGH THE NATION'S
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT LOCAL
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
WELL WE OBVIOUSLY CAN'T CAN THE
LOCAL STORE AND EVENING WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT FUTURE AND I'M
FINDING WILL MATERIAL. I'M NOT
OPPOSED THIS IS A GREAT WINDOW
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME TOGETHER
TO EFFECTIVELY MOVE TOWARD
WHICH OFTEN SHOE OF TRANS
BOUNDARY FLOWS OF WATER. ASH.
ALTHOUGH COMMERCE ARE PULLMAN
YOU CAN CLEARLY THERE'S A OF.
TO ADDRESS THIS HEALTH QUIRK.
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESS OF
NEGOTIATING LONG TERM%
COMMITMENTS FROM THE NEW RIVER
AND DUE TO THE URGENCY OF THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY SITUATION
WE ARE HOPEFUL ANTICIPATE X.
ALREADY COMMANDMENTS OR TO
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY. AND I'LL
STOP RIGHT THERE MAKE SURE BUT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE OR DON'T
HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED DAYS
BEFORE WE HAVE TO APPROVE THE
JUNE FIFTEENTH BUDGET AND JUST
SEE THAT. THIRTY FIVE MILLION.
THE LOCALS IN IN THAT SAN DIEGO
AREA. HELLO YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS. SHARE WITH US OUT WE
THINK BOTH OF THESE PROPOSED
PROJECTS HAVE MERIT THE
POLLUTION PROBLEMS AND- IN THE
TARGETED AREAS ARE VERY SEVERE-
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A ROLE FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THAT. AND MEXICO AS WELL BUT
THE- THAT WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE STATE TO HELP AS
A PARTNER- AS AS MR DRIVERS
NOTED OUR CONCERN IS REALLY
AROUND THE TIJUANA RIVER
PROJECT IN THE FACT THAT THERE
ISN'T AN ONGOING- SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FOR THE NEW RIVER
PROJECT THERE IS THEY'VE GOT- A
MEMORANDUM WITH LOCAL PARTNERS
THAT THEY WILL. COVER THE
ONGOING COSTS TO THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU INCLUDES TWO YEARS
OF OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
BUT IT SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND SO- WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER TWO YEARS WE
THINK YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
BEFORE YOU APPROVE THESE
FINDINGS CONSTRUCT THESE
PROJECTS. PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
WE WANT TO PROJECTS TO WORK AND
SERVE THEIR PURPOSE SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND. THAT YOU DON'T
APPROVE THE FUNDING UNTIL YOU
HAVE A PLAN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR HOW THOSE
COSTS WILL BE FUNDED NOW MAYBE
IT WILL HAVE TO BE THE STATE.
FUNDS THOSE GOING COST BUT YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT WE THINK
BEFORE YOU APPROVE THE PROJECTS
AND APPROVED THE FUNDING. RATE
WERE OPTIMISTIC WE GET SOME
TIPS BUT WE THINK YOU SHOULD
HAVE THAT CERTAINTY BEFORE
COMMITTING THE FUNDS.
CLARIFICATION FINANCED. BRING
TO THIS DISCUSSION- PRIME
FULLER PART OF FINANCE- JUST
UNDERSCORING THE PREVIOUS
REMARKS- UNDERSTAND THAT THE
IMPORTANCE OF GUARANTEEING THE
ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FOR THE WATER
PROJECT- THE- CONVERSATIONS
THAT ARE STILL. IN IN
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE LOCAL AND
SEIZE THE STATE ENTITIES THE
VETERANS THESE. M. THE
MINISTRATION. AB IS COMMITTED
TO NOT HAVING CONSTRUCTION
BEGIN UNTIL THAT ONGOING.
FUNDING AGREEMENT IS IN PLACE.
WE'D JUST ONE UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE IN THE TIME
SENSITIVITY THESE CRITICAL
PROJECTS THAT WE WOULDN'T.
RECOMMEND DELAYING ANOTHER
YEAR. AT AS A RESULT OF AN
AGREEMENT. ANGLE THANK. CENTER
MCGUIRE A QUESTION THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT MISTER CHAIR JUST GOING
OFF OF WHAT YOU WERE JUST
SAYING IN THE BEGINNING HERE AT
YOU YOU HAD SAID THAT FUNDING
SHOULD MATERIALIZE SO I THOUGHT
WHAT'S YOUR EXACT WORDS FOR
THEIR WOULD WINTER LIES. OKAY
FINING SHOULD MATERIALIZE
WHATEVER DOWN BUT- SO- GIVES A
GLANCE INTO THAT IF YOU DON'T
MIND. WELL AS I MENTIONED I
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN IN ON ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH- THE
LOCALS AND- WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING TO AND AGAIN NOT AT ALL
TRYING TO BE CRUNCHY BUT ARE WE
TALKING. TWO YEARS FIVE YEARS
ARE YOU LOOKING AT TRYING TO BE
A TO GET SOMETHING IN BY THE
END OF THE YEAR. LOOK I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE I'M MOST FAMILIAR
ON THAT THAT THEY HAD A TIJUANA
RIVER IT IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE. THE CONDITIONS IF
YOU COULD JUST GIVE US A LITTLE
BIT OF A GLANCE OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE. JUST SO WE CAN GET
A BETTER IDEA. YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AS WELL
AND YOU WORK. THANK YOU CENTER
I CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR BORDER AFFAIRS
HAS BEEN DILIGENTLY WORKING ON
ON ON THIS. UNFORTUNATELY SHE
COULD BE HERE TODAY. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MO YOU
WITH THE ENTITY BALK CALIFORNIA
BASSER ARE SORT OF. AB IS STILL
TAKING ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND
FOR ME TO GIVE YOU A TIME LINE
I DON'T HAVE THAT FOR YOU
TODAY. BUT I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION I SUSPECT THERE IS-
ONGOING MEETINGS AND
DELIVERABLES AND AYE AYE MY
COMMITMENT TO YOU AND TO ALL OF
THE MEMBERS WOULD BE TO GET YOU
A BETTER TIME LINE THAT. SHE TO
INTO THE CHAIR IF IT WOULD BE
ALRIGHT ADD TO ASK THE DIRECTOR
JUST TO BE ABLE TO. I'M HIGHER
TO US TAKING FINAL ACTION IN
THIS COMMITTEE ON ALL ITEMS
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL IF WE
CAN GET THAT TIME LINE THROUGH
THE CHAIR- IF YOU'D BE WILLING.
THAT WE CREATE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE MIGHT JUST HOLD AFTER.
REQUEST ADVICE FOR COLLEGE. YES
I'M AND I'LL SAY THAT WHILE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS FINDING
CONSTRUCTION THE CANYONS AND
LOCAL ENTITIES HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ALSO EXPLORING HOW TO FIND MAIN
CHANNEL SOLUTIONS THROUGH-
THROUGH MEXICO AND IS COMMITTED
UPGRADING FACILITIES IN TIJUANA
I WILL ALSO SAY HISTORICALLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
INVESTED OVER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION AN IMPROVING
SEWAGE INFRASTRUCTURE AFFECTING
THE BORDER REGION OF THE
TIJUANA RIVER. AND MORE
RECENTLY THE UNITED STATES
CANADA MEXICO AGREEMENT ALSO-
DIRECTS THREE HUNDRED MILLION
TWARDS A BORDER WASTE WATER
PROJECTS AND THERE MAY BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THAT FUNDING
TOWARDS THESE PROJECTS. IT WILL.
I AM. DO WE NOTED THAT THAT
THAT IS TYPICALLY THE CASE BUT
AGAIN AS I MENTIONED IN AND OUT
EARLIER IN MY TESTIMONY THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US TO
GET THIS RIGHT AND- SORRY NEWS.
YES IS THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO I
MENTIONED SOME OTHERS I HAVE A
HOLD WE HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF
FOLKS THAT ARE AT THE TABLE.
AND I ALSO- SKIS ME CENTERS I
APOLOGIZE I ALSO BELIEVE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT- THERE FROM.
THOSE AREAS THAT COULD SPEAK TO
THIS IS WELL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JUST ONE THING TO ADD
SINCE IT HASN'T BEEN RAISED
THAT FOR THE NEW RIVER THE
TERMINATION OF THE NEW RIVER IS
THE SALTON SEA WHICH HAS BEEN
A- TOPIC OF CONVERSATION HERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND WHERE THE
STATE HAS SOME. I'M SPECIFIC
RESPONSIBILITIES AROUND AIR
QUALITY WATER QUALITY AND
HABITAT SO. THAT THAT WAS WHY
THERE WAS TEN MILLION INCLUDED
IN PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FOR
THE NEW RIVER AND I'M JUST IN
ANOTHER LAYER OF STATE
IMPORTANCE TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION GOOD ALL RIGHT
LET'S OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS THE NEW REFER.
HI PROJECT YOU WANNA. RIVER
PROJECT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SURE- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JONATHAN CLAY HERE ON BEHALF OF
A COUPLE THOSE ENTITIES THAT
ARE BEING DANGLED THE DOLLARS
IN FRONT OF- COUNTY SAN DIEGO
AND THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND
SUPPORT- A LITTLE BIT MORE FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING
WORKED ON THIS FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS MY ENTIRE CAREER HERE-
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO WAS THE
LEAD ENTITY IN SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- LAST YEAR
OVER THIS ISSUE BECAUSE OF. A
LACK OF CONTINUED FUNDING IN
THIS IN THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT'S GOING ON AT LEAST SINCE
THE EIGHTIES A MY MEMORY AND
PRE DATING EVEN THEN- I THINK
THERE IS SOME OF THE LOT
OPPORTUNITY GOING ON AS WAS
DISCUSSED THERE'S MOVEMENT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL FOR A RENEWED
COMMITMENT OF FUNDING- I THINK
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE BEEN
DURING THE BRUNT OF THIS FROM
YOU PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
IN TERMS OF POLLUTION. TELL A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE STAND READY TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT BOTH
FROM THE THIRTY FIVE MILLION
THAT'S PROPOSE NOW THE FIFTEEN
MILLION THAT WAS IN THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR FOR ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS TWO YEARS BEFORE THAT
WITH US IN A WAY SO WITH SB
FIVE OF SEVEN WHEN THE COUNTY
ACTUALLY CONDUCTED ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT PROJECTS NEED TO BE
BROUGHT TO THE TABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE WHICH IS THE PRICE
TAG BROWN'S. BORN EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE- ARM. HE
SAID TO SUPPORT THIS KNOB
ROLLED SLEEVE AND TALK FOR THE
ABOUT. WHAT THE COST. WITH LOOK
LIKE A KNOWN AS- THANK YOU NEXT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ME GET IF YOU GET A
LOT ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER FOR
THE CITY OF CALEXICO. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT I WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALEXICO IN YOUR RIVER
COMMITTEE THE NONPROFIT THAT
COSPONSORED ASSEMBLY BUILT IN
SEVENTY NINE. THIS BILL
CREATED- WAS TASKED WITH
CREATING A TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE- THAT WAS MANDATED-
BY THE BILL- TO CREATE AT THE
NEW RIVER IMPROVEMENTS
STRATEGIC PLAN. A PLAN THAT
WOULD CONSIDER ALL THE
IMPAIRMENTS CONSIDERING MEXICO
ALL THE WAY TO THE SALTON SEA-
THE MATTER THAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU HERE AND FOR WHICH
A SECURE SUPPORT. IS THAT THE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE FUNDED.
WITH THE RESOURCES FOR THE NEW
RIVER IMPROVEMENT PROJECT ARE
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
THROUGH A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
WAS APPROVED IN ADOPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
RELATIONS COUNCIL IN TWENTY
TWELVE. I DO WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT THE RIVER ISSUE AS YOU
FOLKS ARE AWARE HAS BEEN A
PUBLIC THREAT ISSUE FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF IMPERIAL COUNTY
FOR SEVENTY FIVE YEARS. WE
COULDN'T WE CONSIDER CALEXICO
GROUND ZERO. WHY BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE NEW RIVER PASSING IN
THE BACKYARDS OF FOUR HUNDRED
HOMES. FOUR HUNDRED HOMES THAT
ARE CALIFORNIANS WE NOW HAVE A
SHOVEL READY PROJECT. WE NOW
HAVE THE COMMITMENT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL OF OUR LOCAL
UTILITY IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. THE COUNTY OF
IMPERIAL AND THE CITY OF
CALEXICO TO COVER THROUGH
ANIMAL YOU THAT HAS A TWENTY
YEAR TERM THAT WAS SIGNED IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. TO
COVER THE OWN M. OF THE THREE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENTS THAT
WOULD BE. BUILT OUT TO THE
FUNDING. THAT'S A DENT TO FIGHT
IN YOUR PACKET SO WITH THAT
SAID I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
TAX. GOOD MORNING OR AFTERNOON
PUBLIC GUYS WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND- STRONG SUPPORTER
OF THE MONEY THE FUNDING FOR
THE NEW RIVER PROJECT TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC HEALTH AND WATER
QUALITY IMPACTS IN CALEXICO AND
THAT THE SALTON SEA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE TALKS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO- WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT ON
THE ITEM RELATED TO THE TIJUANA
RIVER- AS MY COLLEAGUE WITH THE
COUNTY INDICATED WE HAVE BEEN
BEARING THE BRUNT OF- OF THE
POLLUTION. FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AND DECADES I'M SO WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE EFFORTS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT
FORTH- TO OUR TO COALESCE NOT
JUST US BUT THE FEDS AS WELL.
MNC SOME UNIQUE- ARRANGEMENTS.
CURRENTLY AND WE LOOK FORWARD%
TO CONTINUING THAT DIALOGUE
THROUGH THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
THANKS. ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE. WE'LL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING I'D
LIKE TO. DO THIS IN TWO PARTS
IS THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION-
HAS SAID SO THE FIRST MOTION
WOULD BE TO APPROVE THE- AB. B.
C. P. FOR THE NEW RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT. THERE'S A
MOTION IS THERE'S A MOTION BY
CENTER MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MY CASKEY HI ALI. WHEN
MONEY. HOLD THAT MATTER OPEN WE
WILL HOLD. THAT FACT YOU WANNA
MATTER. GOOD LUCK. NEGOTIATE
BUT ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THIS
IS THE SIGMA THIS IS SYMBOL
GROUND MANAGEMENT PROGRAM- THE
GOVERNOR HAS A- THIRTY NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL THIRTY SOME POSITIONS
GO AHEAD. WITH ME IS A MISTER
KEITH WALLACE OF FROM OUR
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT OFFICE. I'M THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REQUESTS
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND FOR STAFFING
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FOR GRANTS TO
THE NINETEEN CRITICALLY
OVERDRAFT GROUND WATER BASINS
THAT ARE BEGINNING TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR LOCAL BROWN WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS. THIS
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
TO SUPPORT PLANNING AND PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION NEEDED TO
ADDRESS A BROADER ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION.
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO EACH OF
THE LOCAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
LEADING THE BASINS OVERALL
EFFORTS. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
IDENTIFYING A ECONOMIC
DISRUPTIONS AND EXPLORING WAYS
TO ADDRESS THEM. THOSE LOCAL
GROUND WATER AGENCIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO COORDINATE WITH THE
OVERLYING COUNTY TO ENSURE
THESE EFFORTS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH COUNTY PLANNING AND
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS. WE ARE
AWARE OF THE ALIENS%
RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION REGARDING
THE FUNDING A PROPOSED FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE IN THIS ITEM
AND WE WOULD BE PLEASED TO WORK
WITH THE SUB SUB COMMITTEE IN
THE LA- AND DEVELOPING
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE LANGUAGE.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
STAFF COMMENTS THAT REFERENCE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE ADEQUACY OF LOCAL
GROUNDWATER PLANS IN ADDRESSING
IMPACTS TO DRINKING WATER WELLS.
THE DEPARTMENT SHARES IN THE
CONCERNED ABOUT IMPACTS TO
DRINKING WATER WELLS. LOWERING
OF GROUND WATER LEVELS AFFECTS
ALL ELEMENTS OF SICKNESS
PRIORITIES A DEGRADED WATER
QUALITY SUBSIDENCE SEA WATER
INTRUSION AND DEPLETION OF
INTERCONNECTED SURFACE WATERS.
E. W. R. IS REQUIRED TO REVIEW
THE GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS. FOR THEIR ABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THESE
IMPACTS AND THE PLANSMUST
IDENTIFY IMPACTS OF CONTINUED
GROUNDWATER DEPLETION ON EACH
OF THESE CONDITIONS AND THEY
MUST IDENTIFY HOW THESE IMPACTS
ON ALL BENEFICIAL USES ARE
CONSIDERED AND ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THEIR PLANS. OUTSIDE THE
SPECIFIC REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS OF SIGMA THE STATE
HAS SEVERAL PROGRAMS THAT
INTERFACE WITH GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT INCLUDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER EFFORTS WATER
STORAGE PROJECTS AND THE
CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL WATER
SYSTEM. IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA
REQUIRES CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH THE STATE WATER BOARD
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
SB TWO HUNDRED SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SENATORS GREAT EFFORTS.
THOSE DOLLARS. TO DO TO SOLVE
THE DRINKING WATER PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT T BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT IN
ADMINISTERING A SIGMA THE
DEPARTMENT'S VIEW IS THAT SB
TWO HUNDRED FUNDING IS NOT A
SOLUTION TO ADDRESS FURTHER
WATER QUALITY DEGRADATION. THAT
MAY BE DISCLOSED IN THESE
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS- WE EXPECT THAT THOSE
PLANS WILL NEED TO ARTICULATE
SEPARATELY HOW THEY ARE
DRESSING DOMESTIC WELL IMPACTS-
THAT COULD ARISE AS THE AS A
RESULT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE PLANS. E. W. R. IS JUST
IN THE BEGINNING OF ITS PLAN
REVIEW WE RECEIVED FORTY FIVE
PLANS- BY THE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST DEADLINE- AND WE
ANTICIPATE MANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
BEFORE THE APRIL FIFTEENTH AND
MAY FOURTH DEADLINES- ON THOSE
PLANS. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING-
INTENSIVELY WITH MEMBERS FROM
THE- ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY THEY'VE BROUGHT- VERY
GOOD IDEAS TO THE TABLE
INCLUDING. A MITIGATION PLAN IF
YOU WILL FOR DOMESTIC- WELL
MITIGATION- THAT KIND OF OVER
ALL. A POLICY IDEAS AND
APPROACHES VALLEY VERY HELPFUL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AS WE START
THE PROCESS OF EVALUATING-
THOSE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PLANS. SO WITH THAT- I'D BE
DELIGHTED TO ANY QUESTIONS.
LET'S HEAR FROM YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR US SO AS STRICTER
NEMETH NOTED YOU HAVE TO
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU ONE IS
NINE POINT SIX MILLION AN
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR.
SUPPORT OF DEPARTMENT TO PLAY
THEIR ROLE I AND THEN THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE SO ON THE FIRST
PIECE WE WOULD RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE FUNDING WE THINK
OF SIGMA'S OBVIOUSLY A VERY
LARGE PRIORITY FOR THE STATE
AND IS AT A CRITICAL POINT OF
ITS IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT. PLAYS AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN HELPING SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT. ON
THE AS AS A DIRECTOR NOTED ON
THE ONE TIME LOCAL ASSISTANCE
WE THINK THERE IS A NEED IN A
ROLE FOR THE STATE TO HELP
SUPPORT THESE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS THAT ARE IN THE
ON THE FRONT LINES THAT REALLY
STARTING TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
PLANS. BUT WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT SOME PARAMETERS
AROUND THAT FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S FOCUSED ON PUBLIC BENEFIT
NOT PRIVATE BENEFIT. AND ALSO
THAT IT IS REALLY HELPING TO-
IMPLEMENT. GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS AFFECT OF
LEAVE IT I'M THAT THAT IS THE
ROLE OF THE STATE AND THAT THE
STATE DOLLARS SHOULD BE
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON. THE STATE
ROLE IN HELPING CALLS IMPLEMENT
THIS ACT THERE ARE GONNA BE
LOTS OF OTHER IMPACTS FROM
SIGMA THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
SCOPE OF THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY SO WE THINK
PUTTING SOME PARAMETERS AROUND
THAT FUNDING IS IMPORTANT.
CENTER MONNING. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WASN'T HERE
EARLIER I DO WANT TO WELCOME
VICE CHAIR DOLLY TO THE
COMMITTEE WELCOME ABOARD NICE
TO HAVE YOU WITH US AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT
FOR YOUR WORK IN. ON LA FOR
YOUR AY. SO MY QUESTIONS DO GO
DO YOU TOUCHED ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS. THERE IS
A REQUIREMENT OF OUTREACH TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WHAT
IS THE EXPECTATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT HOW THAT IS
IMPLEMENTED IN WHAT'S THE
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE. IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN AN
EFFECTIVE MANNER SO THE
DEPARTMENT- ISSUED- BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AROUND OUT
REACH TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE ALSO.
PROVIDED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS TO ASSIST IN THOSE-
GSA'S OF DOING OUTREACH TO A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- AS
THE PLANS COME IN AND OF COURSE
RIGHT NOW. IN IN MULTIPLE
PHASES SO- THE PLANS
THEMSELVES- WERE HAVE RELEASED
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- IN OCTOBER
AND THEY HAD MOSTLY IN A NINETY
DAY PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD WHERE
STAKEHOLDERS COULD PROVIDE
COMMENTS TO THE ACTUAL GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY-
THOSE PLANS ARE THEN ADOPTED.
THEY WERE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT
HAS OPENED ITS OWN PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD- ON THOSE PLANS
SO WE ANTICIPATE- OUT OF THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT TO GET- SOME
SIGNIFICANT FEEDBACK- THAT I
THINK THERE'S OF A- SAFE TO SAY
THERE'S SOME REAL VERY ABILITY.
AND HOW THE DIFFERENT GROUND
WATER. TESTING ABILITY AGENCIES
WHEN ABOUT REACHING OUT TO-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
AND WE WILL BE ASSESSING EACH
PLAN INDIVIDUALLY AS TO THE-
WHETHER OR NOT A OUTRAGE DONE
APPROACH. AND PUT WAS PROVIDE
AN INPUT WAS RESPONDED TO I'M
SO THAT IS ALL TO THAT IS ALL
TO COME- IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE ITS OWN
GUIDANCE OUT AS THOSE PLANS ARE
UNDER DEVELOPMENT AND THAT WILL
BE SOMETHING THAT. WE WILL USE
TO. HELP MEASURE THE ADEQUACY
OF THE PLAN OVERALL. I
APPRECIATE THEM. YOU DID
MENTION IN YOUR- OPENING
COMMENTS. PROTECTION OF SB TWO
HUNDRED FUNDING FOR ITS
INTENDED PURPOSE. BUT AGAIN
WITH RESPECT TO THE COMMUNITY
OUT REACH THAT'S THAT'S
REQUIRED IT'S EXPECTED THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THEM.
NECESSARILY INVOLVES AN
INFORMED PUBLIC THAT HAS%
CAPACITY TO ENGAGE IN THAT
SWEAR I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT THE ENVIRO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
IN ADVOCATES BUT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY POSITIONED IN
EVERYONE OF THESE COMMUNITIES
EITHER SO I THINK THE CONCERN
IS THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL GAP
BETWEEN. EVEN WELL INFORMED
ADVOCATES ABILITY TO LIAISON
WITH SOME OF THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE THAT AREN'T NECESSARILY
COME ON THE RADIO ARE OR ARE
ACTIVELY ENGAGE SO. WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE TECHNIQUES YOU'LL
USE TO VERIFY I GUESS OUR
CONCERN IS THAT SOME OF THE
PLANS WILL CHECK A BOX THING WE
DID COMMUNITY OUT REACH. BUT
HOW DO YOU GO BELOW THAT
CHECKING THE BOX TO VERIFY. A
REAL ENGAGEMENT WITH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO
THE END OF MAKING SURE WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER AS PART OF THE
SUSTAINABILITY. YES A ONE WAY
WE CAN ADDRESS IT IS THROUGH-
SO WE WON'T THE DEPARTMENT WILL
MAKE AN EVALUATION AND AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A STATUTORY
OBLIGATION TO COMPLETE THAT
EVALUATION WITHIN TWO YEARS OF
RECEIVING. THE PLANS I'M IN IN
THAT CONTEXT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN- FIND AN INADEQUACY
DETERMINATION AND THAT'S WHEN
WE ENGAGE WITH THE BOARD- BUT
IN FINDING ADEQUACY WE CAN ALSO
PROVIDE FOR CORRECTIVE ACTIONS.
AND SO YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE-
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT.
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES WHERE-
THE TIMING OF THEIR PUBLIC
MEETINGS- BEING IN THE
AFTERNOON OR THEY'RE LACKING IN
TRANSLATION SERVICES OR THEY
MAKE ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT- THE
FEASIBILITY OF A WELL
MONITORING AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE ALL DOING
IT IN A- A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
WAY- IRRESPECTIVE OF THE BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES BUT- THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY ON. IN PLANTS THAT ARE
SUCCESSFUL TO ISSUE CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS THAT- SENSUALLY- IN
ABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION ON THE QUALITY OF
THE INPUT AND THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA. AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE OUR APPROACH FOR A VALUE.
WAITING THE ABILITY OF IMPORT
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL INFORMATION AND
CONTINUE TO PRIDE TECHNICAL
INFORMATION AS THE PLAN ITSELF
IS IMPLEMENTED. PART OF THE
DYNAMIC OF SIGMA AS YOU KNOW IS
WE HAVE IN PERFECT INFORMATION
SO WHAT'S ENOUGH INFORMATION
WITH THE RIGHT STRUCTURE WITH
THE ABILITY TO INVOLVE ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE COMMUNITY-
TO. DEVELOP A PLAN THAT'S
ADEQUATE BUT THAT BY DEFINITION
IS GOING TO IMPROVE OVER TIME
AND WE HAVE THOSE CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS AVAILABLE TO US TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A HIGH
QUALITY. PARTICIPATION I'M NOT
JUST IN THE PLAN AS IT WAS
DEVELOPED BUT AS THE PLAN IS
IMPLEMENTED OVER TIME THANK
UNITS SOUNDS LIKE. YOU RESPOND-
MIKE QUESTION KIND OF THE
EVALUATION OF SUBMITTED PLANS
AND HAVE THAT DONE IS THERE ANY
FRONT END DIRECTION GIVEN TO
WHAT IS EXPECTED IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITY OUT REACH. DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU COULD SHARE
WITH US THAT SHOWS HOW THOSE
DEVELOPING THE SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN SO WHAT THE EXPECTATION IS
OF THE DEPARTMENT. OR PROTOCOLS
BEST PRACTICES ALASKA MY
COLLEAGUE KEITH WALLACE THINK
ON IT THE VERY MUCH I AM YES IN
IN COLLEGE EARLIER THAT DO HAVE
GUIDANCE THAT THAT IS AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC TO DEMONSTRATE
THE APPROPRIATE WAY OF GOING
ABOUT ATTACKING PROBE PUBLIC
REACH WHILE IT IS. I SHOULD SAY
YOU KNOW IS THEBEST APPROACH
BASED ON. BEST PRACTICES. YOU
THE LOCAL ARE FOR TO GO ABOUT
IT AND THEY'VE SEE BY FIT. WE
ARE THE PROCESS OF I DO NUMBER
OF WORK SIGNAL FORMS TO EXIT
OVER THE- SEVERAL WERE BRING
THE GROUND SUITABILITY AGENCIES
TO. BOTH OF THOSE PRETTY CLEAR
BY AND GS THAT HAVE ALREADY
SOME THEIR PLAN AND HIGH MEDIUM
BASE. THAT ARE SO IN PROCESS TO
DEVELOP THEIR PLAN. AND WE SEE
THAT A VENN FOR SHE FOR. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DEFINITELY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND WE HAVE
ON OUR AGENDA FOR THIS YEAR IS
OUR REGION ENGAGEMENT. WE KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH THE NGO COMMUNITY-
TO IDENTIFY AREAS THAT THEY
FELT WERE HANDLED VERY WELL.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE IDENTIFY THOSE GSA'S
AND ALLOW THEM TO SHARE THE
PRACTICES THEY'VE CONDUCTED-
WITH THE OTHER GSA'S TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
WHERE- THE THOSE THOSE
BENEFICIAL APPROACHES CAN BE
YOU KNOW CARRIED ON OVER-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
SO I THINK WHAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO US IF YOU HAVE ANY
MATERIALS THAT ARE BEING SHARED
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE THAT
KIND OF SHARE BEST PRACTICES
AND EXPECTATIONS. THAT'S KIND
OF AT THE FRONT END AND THEN AS
YOU EVALUATE SUBMITTED PLANS.
AND WHAT YOUR CHECKLIST WILL BE
TO VERIFY THAT AGAIN THEY'RE
NOT JUST CHECKING A BOX THAT WE
DID COMMUNITY OUTREACH. SO
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED WORK
ON THEN. LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU BYE SAID. HER. DOLLY
HI THIS MY CONCEDED WORKS WILL.
SO HOW DO YOU IDENTIFY DO YOU
VIRUS TO COME UP DISADVANTAGED.
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE HOW DO YOU
WITH THIS IS BEEN A OF. A LOT
OF FRUSTRATE FOR THOSE OF US
WHO HAVE AIR FOR MOST OF THE
YEAR AND THEN. WE GET BUMPED
OUT ON ALL KINDS OF GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE OF THAT
AND THEN ALSO- PEOPLE OF COLOR
SO THEY'RE THE THEY'RE VIRUS
GREEN REALLY ISN'T THAT WHERE
WE TRY TO ADDRESS THIS OVER
TIME. AND WE'VE NEVER BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH IT SO I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THE CRITERIA IS
BECAUSE I KNOW- IN MY SENATE
DISTRICT IF THERE ARE. BASINS
THAT ARE. GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND THEY ARE. OUR
HAPPEN TO COME UP THE
RESOURCES. THEMSELVES TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD AND IT'S DIFFICULT FROM
FROM TO DELIVER GRANT PROGRAM
PERSPECTIVE. THERE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT WILL USE ENVIRO SCREEN. I
WOULD BUT I WOULD SAY THE VAST
MAJORITY THE APARTMENT GRANT
PROGRAMS UTILIZE THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY A DEFINITION
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
SO THAT INFORMATION IS GATHERED
BY BY THE AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY AND THEN. YOU WE UTILIZE
THAT INFORMATION WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
TOOL THAT WE PUBLISHED THROUGH
OUR WEBSITE THE THAT HIGHLIGHTS
WHAT AREAS ARE CONSIDERED
DISADVANTAGED. BOTH AND ALSO
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. THIS BUT THIS.
THESE FUNDS ARE. GOING TO BE
FOR POSITIONS AND IT'S NOT
GONNA BE A GRANT PRO THAT WILL
HELP THOSE COMMUNITIES CRACKED.
THE NINE POINT SIX MILLION THE
THREE SOME POSITIONS ARE
GENERAL FUND. IN AND ALSO THE
THIRTY MILLION IS ALSO GENERAL
FUND AS WELL AND- RIGHT NOW- IT
IS TO EAT YES IT IS NOT TIED TO
ANY BOND FUNDING. TO CLARIFY
SENATOR NAME WHAT SIX IS FOR
DEPART THE THIRTY MILLION IS
LOW ASSIST SO GO TO GROUND
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES BUT
THERE PROPOSAL IS NOT TO SELECT
CERTAIN BASED ON INCOME OR
DISADVANTAGED STATUS IT WOULD
BE TO EACH OF THE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASINS THAT ARE.
KIND OF ON THE FRONT LINES
HAVING TO SUBMIT THEIR PLANS
FIRST THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY.
DISADVANTAGED TEST IF YOU WILL
FOR WHO WOULD GET THAT FUNDING
FOR THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
RIGHT NOW. OKAY SO I'M TRYING
TO GET A IDEA WHAT THEIR ROLE
WOULD BE. BUT WITH THESE
POSITIONS THERE'S THIRTY SEVEN
POSITIONS OR WHAT WITH THE ROLE
BE. THE THERE WOULD BE TWO
PURPOSES ONE IS TO BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO ROLES UNDER CIGNA ONE
IS TO PROVIDE FORMER REGULATORY
ROLE. THAT'S TO- REVIEW- THESE
GRAMMAR CIVILITY PLANS ARE
PRESENTED TO US. THE SECOND IS
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- AND NATURAL SYSTEMS
PROVIDED. THROUGH IT'S IN PLAIN
ENGAGEMENT WE HAVE DEDICATED
STAFF THROUGHOUT EACH OF OUR
REGIONAL OFFICES. THAT ARE
SIGNED EACH OF OUR TIME BEING
PARTY BASINS- IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY- THEY ARE A CONDUIT
BETWEEN. THE LOCAL GRAMMAR
AGENCIES AND THOSE REFORM IS AN
OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO WE ALSO
HAVE A NUMBER OF PROJECTS THERE
ARE TUNNELS SYSTEMS PROJECTS.
WE ARE GATHERING DATA LIKE LAND
YOU STATE- COLLECT HYDROLOGIC
DATA- OF THE FIELD IDENTIFY
SUBSIDE INCIDENT THAT WE CAN
MAKE AVAILABLE THERE ARE. THERE
WE VIEW THERE THERE THERE TO BE
AN ECONOMY OF SCALE FOR THE
STATE TO BE GATHERING THIS
INFORMATION PEOPLE TO. BE
PRESENT AT PRESENTED TO- THE
STATE ONLINE. THAT THEY CAN YOU.
RATHER THAN HAVE. THIS
INFORMATION GATHERED A
PIECEMEAL APPROACH. WE HAVE A
TACKLE SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM
WE ACTUALLY MAKE- DRILLING
CONTRACTORS AVAILABLE TO LOCAL
AGENCIES. SO THEY CAN DRILL
DEDICATED MONITORING WELLS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE HAVE.
SUPPORT SERVICES PROGRAM. THAT
WE- MAKE WE HAVE FACILITIES
WILL MAKE AVAILABLE. THE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO WORK OUT
VERY CHALLENGING ISSUES THAT
MAY EXIST. IN THE AND SO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT THESE TO WILL
ABLE TO DO IS ENABLE TO.
CONTINUE PROVIDE THAT SAME
LEVEL OF TO SYSTEMS THAT WE'VE
BEEN. OF ASAL YEARS WELL STILL
BEING ABLE TO REVIEW THE GROUND
SENATE BILL PLANS WE HAVE TO.
AS A AS A AS REQUIRE. TO REVIEW
AND SO IF WE WERE TO. TAKE
EXISTING HE'S WE HAVE NOW WE
WOULD NEED TO APPLY TO OUR
REGULAR REVIEW. AND THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS THAT WE'VE
BEEN PROVIDING WITH BLACK. IS
THIS REALLY A- OUR OVERALL.
PLANS AS THEY. YEAH BUT WE ARE
SEEING SOME OF THE BEATING. WE
THOSE WILL OUT HERE. OUR
LAUGHING NEEDED BOTH. NEW THE
REVIEW AND YOU TOO BYE ASSIST
MEDIUM. IT YOU. YEAH MORE. WHEN
THE DEADLINE ALL TOLD ME HOW
MANY BUT. I LIVE IN A IN A
BASEMENT WITH SO WE HAVE A-
WELLS AND SEPTIC I'M ON A WELL-
BUT WE ARE THE VALLEY THAT I
LIVE I IS ACTUALLY THEY THEY
THIS. AT THE CEMETERY IN A LONG
COUNTY ROADS A. B. THEY CAME IN
AND DRILLED ELLS WE HAVE.
HUNDREDS WELLS ALREADY THERE
THAT JUST. AND WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING FOR SOMETIME
BAGWELL'S. YOU I GUESS MY POINT
IS THAT. IT'S A BIRD IS GONNA
BE A BURDEN ON THOSE OF A THE
LANDOWNERS THERE TO. COME UP
WITH THE COST TO FIGURE OUT
FIRST OF ALL IT'S VERY HARD TO
COLLECT THIS DATA BECAUSE YOU
DON'T KNOW. HOW FASTER
RECHARGES AND THERE'S AND IT
DEPENDS ON PRECIPITATION AND I
MEAN THERE ARE. A LOT OF
FACTORS IN THERE. SO THAT WAS
MY CONCERN I KNOW LAST YEAR WE
DID YOU KNOW I DON'T REMEMBER
THE NUMBER THE BILL THAT WE
TOOK G. GIRAFFE FUNDS TO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS SOMETHING IN IN USED IT
IN THE STATE FOR WHICH I. VOTED
AGAINST I THINK THERE'S A NEXUS
BETWEEN. GLOBAL WARMING IN
GROUNDWATER I'M I OR MAYBE
SOMEBODY CAN EXPLAIN THAT TO ME
BUT- WHATEVER. NO BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT THE HOW WE COLLECT
INFORMATION HOW THE INFORMATION
IS DISTRIBUTED AND HOW AND WHO
GETS TO DO WHAT AND WHO'S
GONNA. WHO'S GONNA UPSET SOME
AS WELL OFF AT SOME POINT. I
THINK THAT THAT WE'RE HEADING
DOWN A PATH OF. LIKE KIND OF
SCARY I THINK FOR A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES THERE RIGHT ON THAT
EDGE. WILL BE IN IN SOME
COMMUNITIES DID A BETTER JOB OF
LIKE. REPORTING OR FINDING
INFORMATION OUT AND IN MY
DISTRICT AND OTHERS WERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST ADVANCE
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES. THEY
ACTUALLY DISSED WERE PUT IN BY
THE STATE AND THEN TRY TO HAVE
TO DIFF IT SO THESE POSITIONS
ARE GOING TO BE. ASSISTING THEM
OR THEY CAN BE REGULATING THEM
LIKE I THAT'S WHAT I REALLY
WANT TO KNOW. THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THESE POSITIONS IS
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE A WE'VE BEEN
PROVIDING OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND INTO YOUR POINT- IN A
WEEK WE ARE COLLECTING DATA AND
TRYING TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
TO LOCAL AGENCIES LIKE YOURS-
SO THAT THEY HAVE AND WE ALSO
HAVE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AS
WELL THAT WE HAVEN'T- AWARDED
IT ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS OR
WILL BE AWARDING A THIRD ROUND
OF WORK ON OUR PURSES IMMIGRANT
WATER MANAGEMENT PLANNING GRANT
FUNDS HERE WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS- TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST. THOSE LOCAL AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE ONE YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THAT THAT REALLY
ARE STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY TO
BE ABLE MAKE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO DEVELOP THESE
REFERENCES INABILITY PLANTS AND
SO THAT'S THAT IS ONE AVENUE
BUT REALLY WHAT WILL BE OUR
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING IS THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE DO HAVE A
REGULATORY ROLE BUT WE WANT TO
USE THE POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN NOT ONLY THAT
REGULATORY FUNCTION WE HAVE TO
REVIEW THE BROWN VERSUS
INABILITY PLANS. BUT ALSO TO
CONTINUE PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT WE THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE THANK YOU TO OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE BAKER WITH THEIR
GRIEVANCES SEATS FOR THE TWO.
ENGINEERS CAL. GOVERNMENT HERE
TO SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. WE REPRESENT THE
ENGINEERS IT'LL ACTUALLY BE
DOING THIS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. OTHERS A FEW ISSUES
AT STAKE IN THIS PROPOSAL- WE
SUPPORT THE POSITIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
NAME'S DAVE YOURS WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER I WANT
TO START BY THANKING TRACTOR
NAY WITHIN HER STAFF. FOR THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE SO FAR ON
SEGMENTATION WORKING WITH US
ESPECIALLY ALL THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE ON ON WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON
THE GROUND. ON THE GROUND WE'RE
SEEING. NUMEROUS GSA'S REFUSING
TO ACKNOWLEDGE IMPACTS THE
DRINKING WATER. BOTH QUANTITY
AND THE QUALITY SIDE. AND IF
THAT'S NOT CORRECT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OR STATE WATER BOARD
IN THE GSP REVIEW WE'RE GOING
TO SEE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACCESS. OUR THAT IS CAUSED BY
THE LACK OF OUR REGION
ENGAGEMENT THAT HAS BEEN
OCCURRING THAT CENTER MONNING
BROUGHT UP. BUT IF YOU ARE OUT
REACHING ENGAGING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE AND YOU'RE NOT LISTENING
TO THEIR CONCERNS AND THEIR
NEEDS YOU'RE GOING TO CREATE
PLANS. THAT FAIL TO RECOGNIZE
THE IN SERIOUS IMPACTS TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES I ALSO ONE STATE
THAT. ANALYSIS OF SEVEN GS
PIECE DONE BY CLEAN MORE
ADVOCATES HAVE SHOWN THAT OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND. RESIDENTS
WILL BE IMPACTED BY DEWATERING
OF WELLS POTENTIALLY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT'S JUST SEVEN GS.
GSA'S AND THAT'S NOT INCLUDING
WATER QUALITY IMPACTS OUTSIDE
INCLUDING THOSE WERE GONNA
IMPACTED BY INCREASING
CONCENTRATIONS OF CONTAMINANTS.
THIS IS NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
GSP REVIEW PROCESS THE BURDENS
CAN BE BORNE BY THE STATE
THROUGH THE STATE FOR THE
DRINKING WATER FUND. THE FUN
WASN'T DESIGNED TO ADDRESS POOR
SIGNAL IMPLEMENTATION AND SO
THERE FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE
FUND IS THREATENED. THE REASON
IS COMMITTED TO BEING HELPFUL
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND WE
WILL BE SUBMITTING. SEVERAL G.
S. P. THE- LETTERS DETAILING
THE IMPACTS TO QUANTITY AND
QUALITY. BUT WE HAVE LIMITED
CAPACITY AND WE CAN'T BE
EVERYWHERE SO THERE'S A
QUESTION OF WHAT GOES ON IN
THIS YEAR'S PEAS WERE. THE A B.
C. OR OUR ALLIES ARE NOT
WORKING. SO IN CLOSING I JUST
WANT TO STATE THAT. DURING THE
REVIEW BY THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD THE QUESTION
NEEDS TO BE ASKED HOW IS THIS
PLAN IMPACTING SAFE DRINKING
WATER. IF THAT QUESTION IS AN
ASKED AND CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
ARE NOT MANDATED WE'RE
THREATENING. THE HOW FAR WE'VE
COME TO CREATING A SAFE
DRINKING WATER FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. BUT AFTERNOON
TO THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME'S MICHAEL CLAIBORNE I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I'D START
BY SIMILARLY THINKING- THE
DIRECTOR AS WELL AS THE W. OUR
STAFF FOR SOME REALLY GOOD
MEETINGS WE'VE HAD- AS WELL AS
THE COMMENTS THAT I'VE HEARD
TODAY. I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE
W. OURS TAKING DRINKING WATER
IMPACTS- RELATED TO CIGNA
SERIOUSLY. RIGHT WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT SIGMUND
PULLMAN TATIAN AND THEY STEM
FROM A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST-
WE WORK WITH COMMUNITIES THAT.
WERE THE FIRST TO SEE DR WELLS
IN THE LAST DROUGHT THEY WERE
THE FIRST TO SEE DRY AFTER AYE
WELLS OR THEY WILL BE THE FIRST
TO SEE DR WELLS IN THE NEXT
DROUGHT. AND THEY'VE CONTINUED
TO SEE WELL AS GOOD DRIVE EVEN
AFTER THE DROUGHT ENDED SO THEY
DESERVE THESE ARE CONTINUING
IMPACTS. AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
ROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS THAT WE'VE ENGAGED ON AND
SEEN SO FAR THOSE ARE ABOUT
THIRTEEN PLANS I BELIEVE- ARE
REALLY AN ADEQUATE THERE'S ONE
PLAN IN PARTICULAR THAT WOULD
ALLOW ABOUT 86% A WELLS TO GO
DRIVE DOMESTIC WELLS- AND WE
DON'T WE BROUGHT THAT
INFORMATION TO THE GSP THEY
CAME BACK AND SAID WELL NO
THAT'S- THAT'S NOT RIGHT IT'S
ONLY ABOUT 50% WELLS. AND
THAT'S THAT'S A COMPLETELY
INADEQUATE RESPONSE AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE'RE SEEING
A LOT OF YES PLEASE. SO WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR TODAY- WE
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR D. W. ARE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
IMPLEMENTING THEIR ABLE TO
REVIEW PLANS ADEQUATELY- TO
ADD. REVIEW TO ANALYZE WHAT THE
DRINKING WATER IMPACTS WILL BE
RELATED TO THE ESPYS ESPECIALLY
THE ONES THAT. DON'T HAVE NGOS
DOING ANALYSIS- IN ADDITION AND
THEY OUTRAGE ENGAGEMENT ISSUE
PROPOSITION ONE PROVIDED SOME
FUNDING FOR OUR REGION
ENGAGEMENT. UNFORTUNATELY UNDER
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT DOES
NOT PROVIDE CONTINUED FUNDING
AND THAT'S NOT AN ELIGIBLE
EXPENSE INTERPRET SIXTY EIGHT.
SO THAT'S A GAP THAT NEEDS TO
BE FILLED. AND THEN AS WE
IMPLEMENT THE PROJECTS NEED TO
BE IMPLEMENTED NEAR-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE DIRECT BENEFITS TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TUNING
TO WORK WITH YOU HAVE YOU ARE
AND COMMITTEE THANK YOU. Q.
NEXT AFTERNOON JENNIFER CLARY
CLEAN WATER ACTION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR COMMENTS TODAY
THEY WERE ALL SUPER HELPFUL A
MY ORGANIZATION IS TEAMED WITH
SEVERAL OTHER GROUPS AND THE
WATER FOUNDATION TO REVIEW AS
MANY PLANTS AS WE COULD WE
REALLY LIMITED THE SCOPE OF THE
REVIEW AND WE'RE ABLE TO WORK
YOU THIRTY ONE OF THE FORTY
FIVE PLANS WHICH JUST GOES TO
SHOW WHAT THE RESOURCE NEEDS
ARE AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT IS NOT.
FAIR NOT TO THE TOP OF THE LIST
ABOUT EIGHT OTHER PLANS DON'T
EVEN HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PLAN- THE ONES THAT
DO DON'T ACTUALLY GO TO THAT
THEY MIGHT IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE BUT THEY DON'T
LIKE LOCATE NECESSARILY LOCATE
MONITORING WELLS NEAR THOSE
COMMUNITIES SECTION MEASURE IF
THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THEIR WATER
THEY DON'T LOOK AT THE IMPACTS
OF THEIR OPERATIONS ON THOSE
WATER SUPPLY AND SO I A
SUGGESTED THEY DON'T MEET THE-
REQUIREMENT TO CONSIDER THE
INTERESTS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THAT GOES BACK
TO THE GOVERNANCE ISSUE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE GROUNDWATER
THE STORE IS THAT ARE IN POWER
NOW AND SO THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
INCENTIVE TO REACH OUT TO THOSE
WHO ARE NOT IN POWER AND WE'RE
SEEING THAT ON THE GROUND IN
WHAT'S COMING OUT OF THE PLANTS
AND HOW THEIR RESPONDING TO THE
NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES ARE GOING
TO LOSE THEIR WATER SUPPLY MOST
OF THE PLANS DON'T HAVE
CONCRETE- PLANS FOR HOW THEY'RE
EITHER GOING TO HANDLE DEMAND
MANAGEMENT OR NEW SUPPLY. OVER
THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF THE
PLAN. AND SO WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT IS A STEEP DECLINE.
IN WATER LIKE A CONTINUE TO
DECLINE IN WATER LEVELS FOR
THIS THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
UNTIL SOMEONE COMES IN AND SAY
HEY YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS. AND SO WE
HOPE WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS. AND WE THINK
THAT- YOU SHOULD CONTINUE TO
PAY ATTENTION MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT. WHAT ARE
WE DONE WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIA- I WENT ONLINE
MYSELF- AND MY REALIZATIONS
WITH THE COMMENTS. THOSE MADE
BY A- THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS IN
ADDITION WE WERE- IN ADDITION
TO THAT- TO A JENNIFER CLEAR IT
WAS JUST SAYING- WE TO WERE
PART OF THAT REVIEW TEAM IN
LOOKING AT THESE THIRTY ONE-
PLANS. WHEN I THINGS THAT- HAS
CONSTANTLY COME UP OVER AND
OVER IS THAT THERE IS NO OR A
REAL CONSIDERATION TO THE
IMPACTS TO THE- HE- ASSUMES. OF.
SOME OF THESE PLANS. ARE
SPECIFIC. BY WAY. AND BOB.
PUBLIC WETLAND AS WELL SO WHAT
OF THINGS WE DO. RAY EARLY THIS
MORNING WAS THE NECESSITIES OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF. FISH AND
WILDLIFE CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
DOES NOT HAVE ANY. MAYBE ONE OR
TWO PEOPLE ARE REVIEWING FOR
THE IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE ISSUES TO NATURAL
GROUNDWATER NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE WILL BE PART OF THE- PART OF
THE- IT. DOES STOPPING PROPOSAL
SHOULD BE COORDINATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO REVIEW THOSE IMPACTS ON ON
PUBLIC AND MANAGE WETLANDS
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON-
PUBLIC AREAS OF WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND-
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE%
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING- YOU
WILL ALSO IN TALKING AS
APARTMENT THINK THEY'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB AND NOW OVER THE
RIVERS REALLY NEEDING THE ROAD
WITH THE FIRST PLANES COMING IN
AND WE'RE LOOKING AHEAD AT.
ANOTHER HUNDRED PLUS PLANS THEY
DEFINITELY NEED THOSE
RESOURCES- TO DO- TO DO THE
JOB- WE HEAR SERVICES HERE
SOCIAL COMMENTS OF COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER'S LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL- IN CLEAN WATER ACTION
THAT CITY YOU ACCESS TO
DRINKING WATER IN DOMESTIC WAS
REALLY NEEDS VIEWPOINT
EMPHASIS. AS THE DEPARTMENT
REVIEWS THESE THIS FIRST TRYING
TO PLANS AND FUTURE PLANS AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
DIRECTION AMISTAD AND THIS IS A
FULLY. THE KNOWLEDGE THAT RE
THE THIRTY MILLION IN LOCAL
SYSTEMS WERE ALSO REALLY
PLEASED TO SEE THE DEPARTMENT
OF QUESTIONS FUNDS WE ACTUALLY
ADVOCATED THAT THEY DO SO. SO
IT'S WARY OR HAPPY TO SEE THAT-
WE DO. SHARE SOME OF THE-
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND ELLIE HAVE ABOUT. IN MORE
DETAIL ON THAT THE ECONOMIC
MITIGATION PLANNING DEFINITELY
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING WE NEED
TO. EMBARKON HERE- BUT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME MORE DETAIL ON
WHAT THAT ENTAILS. AND PERHAPS
HAVING THE DEPARTMENT DRAWING
EXPERTISE FROM OTHER AGENCIES
WITHIN THE STATE IN THE GROUND
WATER WAS ONLY SUPPORT FOR YOU
FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S A TASK
FORCE KIND OF. AND WE NEED TO
BE TALKING ABOUT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT JOB TRAINING OTHER
THINGS AS WELL AS WE GO DOWN
THIS PATH SO. LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE THE WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS- BUT GENERALLY SUPPORT
THANK. YOU COULD NEXT. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES JUST
WANT TO STAY THAT AQUA HAS
COMPLETE CONFIDENCE IN THE W.
OURS ABILITY TO. EVALUATE AND
RESPOND TO THE GSP SORT OF
ALREADY BEEN SUBMITTED. IT'S
VERY POSSIBLE THAT SOME OF
THESE G. AT THE ESPYS WILL HAVE
INADEQUACIES BUT LET'S REMEMBER
THAT THE DEADLINE. FOR THE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
TO SUBMIT THEIR PLAN WAS ONLY A
MONTH GO. SO D. W. R. IS IN
THE BEGINNING STAGES OF
EVALUATING THESE GS PEAS AND-
WE WOULD JUST ASK THAT THEY'RE
GIVEN THE TIME AND THE
RESOURCES TO DO THEIR JOB SO
THANK YOU. STATE ELEVEN
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION. OF WE
WOULD LIKE TO- ALSO STATE OUR-
SERIOUS CONCERN WITH THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS ON A DRINKING
WATER WELLS AND THE FACT THAT
WATER QUALITY WATER QUALITY
ISSUES NEED TO BE VERY MUCH
FRONT AND CENTER IN THE
EVALUATION OF- THESE GS PIECES
THEY GO FORWARD ALL. WE'VE
HEARD THINGS THAT AREN'T IN THE
GS PEAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
IN A LOT OF THE T. S. P.'S IS A
RELIANCE ON GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE- BASICALLY SUPPLY
AUGMENTATION AS OPPOSED TO
DEMAND MANAGEMENT IN TERMS OF
HOW TO- HOW TO- COME INTO
PLANTS ALL MY RESERVATIONS BEEN
IN THE GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND- ONE
FIRST THING WE WOULD SAY AT AND
WE WOULD DO OF POINT OUT TO
DEPARTMENT THAT WE KNOW THEY
KNOW THIS VERY WELL AS THE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE IS NOT A
PANACEA. AND THERE CAN BE
SERIOUS IMPACTS THE GROUNDWATER
QUALITY- DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU
PUT THE WATER WHAT'S IN THE
SOIL ALREADY- SO. THIS RELIANCE
ON- ON ON RECHARGE- ON THE PART
OF THESE GS PIECES SOMETHING
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
SCRUTINIZED VERY CLOSELY. AND
THAT THAT. BOTH TECHNICAL OF IF
YOU'RE SCRUTINIZED WHETHER OR
NOT IT IT IT'S A GOOD IDEA. IF
SO WHAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO ALLOW THE
GSA'S TO IMPLEMENTED AND VERY
SPECIFICALLY WATER THE WATER
QUALITY IMPACTS THERE CAN BE
BENEFICIAL IMPACTS- DILUTION
BUT THERE CAN ALSO BE SERIOUS
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON GROUND
WATER QUALITY AND SO ALL THESE
THINGS NEED TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. AS PART OF THE
EVALUATION PROCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
THIS IS THE SYSTEM WIDE. BUTTON
PROVEN PROJECTS NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS GO AHEAD. OKAY
ISSUE TWENTY- I WANT TO START
BY NOTING THE IMPORTANT
COOPERATIVE NATURE OF THIS
PROPOSAL- AND THE NEXT. FLOOD
MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA IS A
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY AMONG
STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
AGENCIES. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
GENERAL FLOOD MANAGEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND A MORE SPECIFIC ROLE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WHILE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE IN RECENT YEARS OUR STATE
EXPOSURE TO FLOOD RISK REMAINS
A SUBSTANTIAL THREAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR
ECONOMY. THESE PROPOSALS
SUPPORT THE DELIVERY OF LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL FLOOD AND
MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS
NECESSARY TO MEET THE STATE'S
OBLIGATIONS TO MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE FOR FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITH THAT
CONTEXT THIS FIRST FLOOD
PROPOSAL REQUESTS NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS SPLIT BETWEEN
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT AND ONE
FOR FLOOD PROJECTS IN SOLANO
SUTTER YOLO COLUSA SAN JOAQUIN
AND SACRAMENTO COUNTIES. THE
PROJECTS INCLUDE SET BACK
LEVEES FIX IN PLACE LEVY
PROJECTS RESTORATION OF
EXISTING WEIR'S AN OUTFALL
GATES AND FLOOD CONTROL SETTING
SETTLING BASIN WORK. THESE
PROJECTS ARE MULTI BENEFIT IN
THAT THEY ADDRESS FLOOD
MANAGEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL AND
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES AND
WATER QUALITY ISSUES OTHER. RG
IT PROJECTS BENEFIT BOTH BIG
AND SMALL COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY. DO
WE TAKE THESE ISSUES ONE BY ONE
THE ONE HAVE CONVERSATION ON
THIS FIRST PART OF GO THROUGH
THE REMAINING FLOOD PROPOSALS
FOR THROUGH THE PROVOCATIONS. A
ISSUE TWENTY ONE ARE URBAN
FLOOD RISK REDUCTION- AMERICAN
RIVER COMMON FEATURES. OF THE
FORTY SIX MILLION AND GENERAL
FUND- IN THIS ISSUE WILL
SUPPORT THE AMERICAN RIVER WORK
UNDERTAKEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE US ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
AND THE SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY. THE FUNDING
WILL SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION
OF LEVY IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE
EAST LEVY OF THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER DOWNSTREAM OF THE
AMERICAN RIVER. SEVERAL OTHER
LEVY AND EROSION CONTROL
PROJECTS IN THE AMERICAN RIVER
SYSTEM AND THE WIDENING OF THE
SACRAMENTO WE'RE AND BYPASS TO
DELIVER MORE FLOOD FLOWS INTO
THE YOLO BYPASS. ESSENTIALLY OF
THIS PROJECT IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT LEVERAGES A ONE AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THE US ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS TO REALIZE THESE
PROJECTS. OTHER THING TO ADD I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
MINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
SCHEDULING OUT- THESE PROJECTS
IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
REQUESTED IN PREVIOUS YEARS SO
THAT WILL BE HELPFUL
INFORMATION. OKAY. MEMBERS THIS
IS ISSUES TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE
IF I COULD ASK THAT WE CALL OUR
MISSING MEMBERS SO THAT THEY
KNOW. MY INTENTION WAS TO HOLD
TWENTY OPEN IN TO APPROVE HIS
BUDGET TWENTY ONE ON THE
AMERICAN RIVER. BUT WHILE THE
VICE CHAIR LOOKS WHEN WE OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS
ISSUES NUMBER TWENTY ON THIS
SYSTEM WIDE FLOOD IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS AND IN. ISSUE TWENTY
ONE ON THE URBAN FLOOD RISK
REDUCTION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
BOTH THE- ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND WHAT APPEARED IN
THE AS THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
IN THE HANDOUT MADE AVAILABLE-
YOU KNOW THESE ARE IMPORTANT
PROJECTS THAT NOT ONLY PROVIDE
LOCAL FLOOD CONTROL BENEFITS
BUT ECOSYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS AND
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY
BENEFITS THAT REALLY SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STREETS
WE STRONG SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL. ROBERT
CORPS FROM THE QUALCOMM GROUP
ON BEHALF OF SAFECO OF A WE-
GET OFF. ON BOTH X. EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT. OF PLEASE DRIVE
RIGHT- ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND ALSO LAST THE EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY THANK YOU OKAY VERY GOOD
WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING.
BRING BACK TO THE DAIS. IT'S
THE CHAIR'S INTENTION TO HOLD
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY. N.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO APPROVE-
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE. I WILL
HOLD ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY OPEN
OTHERS MOTION BY A CENTER DOLLY
ON ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL RICK.
STOPPING BY. WHERE MONEY STERN.
OKAY MON LEAVE THAT MATTER OPEN
THANK YOU EVERYONE WE WILL
LEAVE WE'LL WAIT FOR THE
MEMBERS TO RETURN TO ADD ON ON
THE VARIOUS MISSION. SEE YOU
GUYS NEXT WEEK. MA'AM. THERE'S
NO ONE TIME. YEAH THANKS A LOT.
SEVEN SELECT. THE MONSTERS. IF
YOU. YOUR WORK ON. YEAH. RIGHT.
THIS. YEAH WELL. THIS. FIRST.
THE YEAH BEYOND THE ONE. SINCE
YOU SEE. I AGREE. EVEN AFTER.
YEAH IT. YEAH RIGHT YEAH I KNOW
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE LOSING TWO
DAYS RESULT HAULING AROUND ALL.
WELL ANYWAY. I WILL.
SO IF. OUR
ALRIGHT LET'S THAT WERE BACK ON
THE RECORD LET'S GO TO- ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THESE ARE- WE
SPLIT THEM UP INTO THREE
DIFFERENT REQUEST SO LET'S OPEN
ROLL ON SIXTEEN A WHICH IS THE
STREAM GAUGING- PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DURING THIS
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTETHE-
AYES HAVE IT FIVE ZERO AND
ISSUE NUMBERS- SIXTEEN BE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION
BOARD CONTINUATION OF EXISTING
STAFFING CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DURING. CLOSE ROLE TELL
YOU THE VOTES THAT I SEVEN FIVE
ZERO AND FINALLY- SIXTEEN SEE
THE FLOOD PLANNING RESOURCING
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DURING. CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU
VOTE SIZE SEVEN FIVE ZERO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
HI KIRK HYDRO MINERALOGY AND
SERVICE WATER OBSERVATIONS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS DURING.
CLOSE ROLE TELL INVOLVED THE
VOTE I SEVEN. FIVE ZERO ON
EIGHTEEN WE SPLIT EIGHTEEN THE
NEW RIVER AND THE- TO WANT TO
WANT TO RIVER- WE'RE HOLDING
THE TIJUANA RIVER THIS IS ON
THE NEW RIVER REQUEST ONLY OF
EIGHTEEN MILLION PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS DOLLY STERN.
CLICK FULL TALLY THE VOTE THE
AYES HAVE IT FOUR ZERO.
EIGHTEEN BE A NINETEEN WAS HELD
OPEN AND TWENTY WAS HELD UP AND
LET'S GO BACK TO ELEVEN WHICH
IS PULLED FROM THE VOTE ONLY
THE VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DOLLY STERN.
HELLO FIVE IS THE HIGHER YOU.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
THE AYES HAVE IT FOUR ZERO AND
FINALLY. ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE WITH WHICH IS THE URBAN
FLOOD RISK REDUCTION FORTY SIX
MILLION FROM GENERAL FUND ON.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
REQUIRE STERN. YOU KNOW HE'S
HE'S LEFT HEAVILY. CLOSE THE
ROLE TELL YOU VOTE THE AYES
HAVE IT FOUR ZERO ALL RIGHT WE
ARE ADJOURNED.